I don't know if I can handle that,
but the clock's wrong.
I mean just subtly,
subtly,
and we live.
One of them's wrong.
Which one is it?
I think they're both wrong.
That's all stuff that says 12.
11.
One says 12.
15,
12,
13 on my 12.
13.
Wrong.
This one says 12 slash 14.
That one says 12.
11.
I want to strap c four to this.
And this one I want to spike against the
wall.
Are you ocd with time or with
everything?
With everything.
Yeah,
like my reloading room is disgustingly
perfect and if I load the dishwasher,
all the forks have to be symmetrical in
one side and the spoons have to be in
there.
They're all like all the mugs that tall
ones have to be on one side.
And then I.
Yeah.
Was that all about.
I Dunno,
I think it came back to um,
pull this sucker up to your face.
The uh,
when you,
when everything's the same and
something's not the same,
it's easy.
It's easiest to see that way.
Right?
So like counterfeiting,
like if you're,
if you're buying a chick in a 13 year
old girl in Tiawana and you're going to
want to get the guy for counterfeit
money and do you want to get them for
human trafficking?
Um,
and he starts handing you crappy bills.
The easiest way to spit spot the bills
is to be able to see,
have all of your proper bills all in the
right order.
So the one that's fake is going to stick
out.
And they were like,
Oh man,
I'm only.
You would use that example when you're
going to tijuana and someone's
trafficking human slavery.
But that's a good example.
Counterfeit money.
It is a good example.
And if you have a 13 year old girl with
a bunch of 18 year old girls,
you can see that third year old get a
little bit easier,
right?
Yeah.
So it applies to everything you know.
And if you have like 100,
a bunch of,
if you reload and you have a bunch of
grain bullets and you're going to
measure and then lock them all point
five,
separation and grain.
So it's like one 75,
75 point five,
one 76,
one 74 point five and so on.
When you stack them all together,
the easiest way to to group them instead
of measuring every single one is to look
at them and just put the ones that are
similarly sized all together,
smallest to largest,
and then you can then you can weigh them
in batches.
Have you always been like this?
I think so with everything.
Yeah.
My mostly.
And what about with like when you were
fighting your training,
did you like map out everything to the
wrap up to the detail training notes.
Great.
Greg,
you,
if you watched some of our fights and I
mean you're a cage side for almost all
of mine in the UFC.
You'd hear Greg be like okay,
so that went according to plan or.
All right.
So uh,
let's go ahead and change things up a
little bit because you just got your ass
kicked,
you know,
and then we'd have to adjust.
He's one of the more interesting corner
guys.
He's so much fun.
Yeah,
he's a,
he enjoys it and he seems to like want
you to enjoy it too.
He's like,
all right.
That went amazing,
you know,
it's like,
let's get some deep breaths.
You're doing fantastic.
Yeah.
In between um,
rounds with Michael Bisbing as a five
round fight.
Um,
he comes in and tells me a,
he,
he told,
he told me like a knock knock joke and
then why the chicken crossed the road
joke and I sit in there and there's a
picture of me like critically looking at
him,
I'm like,
I'm going to kill you.
And you're like,
what are you doing?
And he just wanted me to relax.
You just want me to breathe when I was
doing everything that's supposed to be
doing.
And um,
I just needed to,
you know,
he just thought you were too tense.
Yeah,
apparently.
Huh?
What a Dick playing mind games in the
middle of the middle of a fight.
You have one minute to figure out what
to do and what to say to a guy who just
was for five minutes.
Yeah.
Some people have a little more.
Do you know that?
I discussed that yesterday with big John
Big John,
the podcast yesterday.
We fucked up and he forgot to talk about
it during the podcast,
but after the podcast he explained what
happened.
He says that it was the UFC cut man's
fault because he left a giant Glob of
vaseline on yokels.
I.
He didn't want to touch it because he
felt like if he touched it could open
the cut up again.
Yeah.
He called,
I guess it was the guys name tate.
He tried to call and get the guy to come
back in.
The guy wouldn't come back in,
so the corner men tried to come in.
He said,
no.
He's like,
you got to bring the cut and then back
and then he wound up doing it by
himself.
It was the perfect storm.
He said he fucked up.
He said Jojo was definitely planted it
off and he said,
but if you had to do it differently,
he would have a made you all stand up
and be.
He would have made sure that fucking cut
man didn't leave the cage with that big
Glob of asset on the.
I was just talking crap.
Oh,
I was actually complaining about.
Yeah,
it was.
Um,
so,
but that was a giant issue.
It was a 32nd 32nd issue for a guy who
was really wobbled at the end of the
second round.
Yeah.
And my route to the title.
Yeah,
it was a big deal.
It was a bummer,
but it was the perfect storm,
you know,
and,
um,
and now he's fighting for the title,
so,
you know,
hopefully he represents Cuba.
Well,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He,
uh,
he's a freak.
He really is right.
Specimen when like,
it's,
there's so much going on there.
It's like this,
the years of training in that crazy Cuba
Olympic program,
there's phenomenal genetics is
experience and competing.
There's so much going on there with that
guy.
Layers and layers and layers of the
highest level of competition.
Um,
mixed in with a life that I think has
been very complimentary to a mindset of
an athlete,
you know,
he,
he has pretty much been shaped most of
his life to be a highest level athlete.
Um,
tricky part is man whittaker is good.
We're good.
Very good.
He's very good and very young,
you know,
and uh,
whitaker you gotta remember had his knee
blown out in the first round.
He got his knee hyperextending tours,
MCL pretty badly in the first round and
still was able to stuff take downs and
arguably the best wrestlers ever fought
in mma.
Yeah.
Pretty impressive shit.
That's a great fight.
That's a couple of weeks from now.
Shocker.
And what's his face?
Just fought calvin.
Yeah.
Was it,
are you still,
do you still,
are you like,
you're so close to the division,
you're paying attention to it and you're
just recently retired.
Do you still get itchy?
I,
I have a crazy competition bug but not
to fight.
I'm going to do a bunch of Jujitsu this
year.
I'm competing in long gun smart marksman
stuff,
a three gun,
um,
you know,
have you steal stuff.
So what is a long gun?
Is that like,
just like really long range but not.
So there's a bunch of different styles
of competitive shooting,
you know,
there's like guys that run around and
shoot around barricades very quickly.
Um,
and then there's kind of a slowing fire
nra style where you're going standing
offhand or weird shooting positions and
then there's,
it doesn't matter,
it just matters how far you can shoot.
That's it.
Yeah.
I have a buddy he's into that.
He's into banging steel or like a mile
away or whatever the fuck it is.
That's,
that's it.
Crazy ballistic calculations and
literally calculating the curve of the
earth.
Yeah.
Barometric pressure and the temperature
of your ammo to a degree plays a factor.
Sure.
I'm that
every imaginable measurable thing plays
a factor into how the bullet is going to
fly.
That's a,
it's a real touchy subject and hunting
because it's a,
there's a lot of people that are getting
into that with like really long range
shots on animals.
And the question about whether or not
it's ethical and who is it ethical for?
I don't.
I don't know where I stand on that.
Um,
I really love.
I,
I bounced between rifle hunting and
bowhunting.
Um,
as a kid.
Maybe the first time that I took a shot,
I wasn't 100 percent positive.
The animal wouldn't just fall over.
Uh,
I mean my dad scuffed me up,
you know,
um,
and I was like 11.
So there has since then been a
preponderance of responsibility has
always been on the hunter to without
question.
No,
the animal is going to fall right then,
right there.
We're not stocking it for two days,
you know,
I'm not following a blood trail for nine
hours to see an animal.
Hyperventilating.
I'm now the meat's not even good.
Huge adrenaline spike.
You know,
it's like right there.
That's your meat and you're going to go
get it.
Um,
so that's best case scenario.
But even then animals jumped the string.
And how do you do that when you're
shooting something that the bullet
flight is going to be up for six
seconds,
right?
Yeah.
No,
and I wasn't really that long.
How long has it,
like if you're shooting,
say a thousand yards,
a thousand,
three,
three seconds.
That's a long time.
That is a long time.
Animals can take a couple steps in three
seconds for the hearts.
This big size of two fists.
And that's not lot of margin of error.
The wind changing one mile an hour,
one mile an hour at a thousand at a
thousand yards could,
could make you miss that heart.
Wow.
So yeah,
it's,
it's one of those weird sort of things
where people are getting into it because
there's a bragging rights aspect of it.
You know,
he shot this elk at 800 yards and you
know,
most people go 800 yards.
You tell somebody shot some of the 200
yards.
They go,
oh,
so good shot.
That's reasonable ethical.
You know,
if you have your crosshairs on a,
an animal's vitals at 200 yards is
basically a dead animal.
Absolutely.
But you get,
you get to like six,
700,
like that's a tiny little spot you're
aiming at.
Now Shit gets wiggly.
Yeah,
I mean,
and yeah,
I think you're a conservationist.
Yes.
I think I'm a conservationist and you
know,
we're,
we're talking in the tens of millions of
dollars go into conservation from
hunters every single day from,
from hunting and the U,
s,
wildlife,
department of Wildlife.
They don't know how they're going to be
paying for the protection of habitats
without hunting permits because the
number of people that are hunting are
shrinking.
So,
um,
there's a huge influx in question of
about how moral are different styles of
hunting,
what are the best and how are we going
to make sure that we protect these
animals and protect their habitats.
Um,
all the while,
you know,
I was telling you about the elk I shot
at the beginning of the year
and I had a,
I had a clean broadside shot at,
at 600 meters and I was like,
I'm shooting a threeway totally,
super doable,
you know,
I,
I can,
I can do that almost in my sleep on my
home range,
but I'm shooting an animal.
And I was like,
Nah man,
I'm,
let me just walk this guy down another
ridge.
So move up when I come back down.
And uh,
my neck shot was at like 3:20,
you know,
one shot and he sits down.
So there I think the responsibility
always in all things should fall on the
individual.
Um,
but now it's just getting all the
individuals to actually have
responsibility.
That's where it gets really stupid,
really stupid.
There's,
there's just,
there's just people that they're not
good people.
They,
they don't,
they weren't raised well.
Feel good.
Some people in,
in,
in moments.
Yeah.
What do you mean when you say that?
Like my mom and I,
we argue about this a lot.
Like she thinks people are inherently
good,
you know,
and I'm like when you've seen so much of
the bad for.
Yeah,
obviously I'm gonna have a catalyst.
I'm,
I'm not gonna have the most objective
perspective,
but I'm like,
I want to think people are good.
But like I think hunters and jet,
let's just use that as.
Because that's what we're talking about
right now.
Have 100 hunters.
What percentage are going to do the
right thing?
Are going to do the moral thing,
the ethical thing,
the thing that's the best interest for
the animal,
for conservation,
for nature out of,
out of 100.
You know,
if they're on a hunt,
did they say
for sure the majority.
And now it gets down to guesswork as to
what the numbers are,
but I like 60 percent.
I'd say more.
It's,
I would like to think.
I like to think it's in the seventies or
eighties.
I wish it was 100 for sure.
No,
I don't wish anything other than that.
It was just a mistake.
But there's gonna be people that poach.
It's going to be people that cross
property boundaries when they know
they're not supposed to.
It's going to be people that shoot an
animal when the season opens tomorrow
morning and they get there a day early
and they see an animal and they just
say,
fuck it.
I'm just going to shoot it and hang it
and say I shot at the next day.
There's like gray area stuff where
you're,
you're definitely doing something
illegal,
but it's still haunting.
You still have a tag,
you know,
and it still people bending the rules
like when.
And then there's people that just,
you know,
they'll shoot two,
three animals and the only supposed to
shoot one,
they'll hide the meat.
Uh,
there's,
there's always going to be people like
that.
Assholes.
Yeah,
selfish.
it's always going to be people like
that.
Unfortunately.
And the thing about hunting is it so
controversial in a world where 95 to 97,
depending on who you asked,
percent of the people who eat meat,
it's still very controversial to go out
and kill yourself.
It's,
I still can't understand this weird,
um,
in addition to people being,
you know,
maybe moral or immoral or most are good
or bad.
Um,
this,
the contradiction of people not even
using their brains,
you know?
Um,
I,
I had the best Tacos I've ever had in my
life last week and it have to getting
waterboarded right?
Yep.
Maybe they tasted extra sweet,
but I had a bunch of friends over.
We had some wine from right,
right next door to where my parents,
like where I grew up and that the
animal,
the elk we're cooking meant.
I saw it for a day as I walked this
thing down.
I mean it most beautiful majestic
creature.
I'm like I said I was 600,
moved into unjust under three or right
at three.
And so I got to see it in life.
I got to see it at its death.
I got to see after death,
you know,
I have,
um,
I have the whole entire trophy.
I,
you know,
just just like you.
But I have two freezers,
a garnered six,
almost 600 cumulative pounds from the
hide the head and the meat for just shy
of 400 pounds of meat off that thing.
I still have two freezers full of meat,
you know,
it's a big animal.
It's a big end of delicious.
Good.
It's so good.
It's the best for you too.
It just feels different.
So good in your mouth.
It's the best for you and your mouth.
Yeah.
That's best for your body to.
I feel like it charges me up.
I want to fight velociraptors after,
as like,
oh,
I want to go to Columbia to where the
good stuff is.
Steal some of the good,
like the old
Pablo Escobar style coke and then bring
that back to wherever I am.
And I think that's the equivalent of
what good elk tastes like in your mouth.
I've never done good coke or bad coke,
so I've never done any coke,
but judging from the amount of money
that Pablo Escobar made and the way that
people talked about it,
um,
and how rich means delays,
I think it's pretty good stuff.
Um,
so I'm just,
use is definitely a high demand.
Yeah.
So this is the contrast of the
contradiction would be like people who
are animal rights lovers.
It'd be like you just talked about this
majestic animal that you watched and you
admired and then you shot it and killed
it.
Yeah.
God is beautiful.
You can see that.
Yeah.
I still love it.
I love every single ounce of it.
I know and I,
I agree with you,
but for people that are,
you know,
maybe animal rights activists or many of
them have ever been to,
not that I'm dogging on the cattle
industry because I'm not a,
I think they try to do the best that
they can with what they have to produce
enough food to feed a huge ever growing
population.
I mean this is,
this is a hard thing.
Um,
you've been to one of those farms.
I have,
yeah.
Um,
I don't have the good ones and I've been
the bad ones.
Yeah.
I know how my,
my animal died and it died fast,
peacefully,
right?
Where it loved being.
And I'm never felt anything.
Never saw anything.
It just crumbled.
Yeah.
There's also the balance of life to
there.
There's just,
unless you want to bring wolves and
mountain lions into Texas and to
wherever,
you know,
you're hunting,
you tried that,
that's not working.
It's not working.
No.
They brought the wolves and now they're
looking to hundreds like me to come into
balance the wolves because the wolves
are decimating the herds a to,
to a degree that they've never seen
ever.
Because there's,
there's no balance,
there's nothing to balance the wolves.
So what was the amount of available food
resources.
Now the wolves are just killing
everything.
So even yellowstone and they're like,
um,
can,
can we bring in some pro hunters to try
and balance this?
They docked on the herd in yellowstone
by 90 percent at one point.
Ah,
90 percent this from the wolves they
brought in the nineties.
They're like,
okay,
well we lost the wolves from the sixties
to the eighties,
so let's bring back some wolves in the
nineties and think that we can balance
things and while it paid a positive
effect for about 10 years,
then 20 2010 rolls around.
They're like,
wait,
wait a second.
They're killing entire hurts.
Like we might lose all indigenous elk
here if we don't do something
immediately.
Um,
so now they're bringing in guys like me
to dark them and retry and relocate them
and bring whatever.
Well,
the whole idea behind it was so crazy.
They went and got these giant Canadian
gray wolves and brought them over here
in,
into a place where the animals had,
you know,
they had no knowledge of walls.
They had wiped out the wolf population
and the size of the wolf is bigger than
what was originally here.
So naturally the amount of calories
that,
that wolf needed was greater.
Um,
and with,
with a hundred years of lack of
evolution for the animals that were
there to know what to do.
Yeah,
it was just fish in a barrel for these
wolves that had adapting though they're
adapting,
adapting quick,
but they're still getting jacked.
The part of the problem is people say,
well,
it's there.
They're killing the weak animals,
but they're not the weak ones.
Go down into the farm lands you're
getting like the the cows and the
calves,
the smaller elk,
the female and the babies.
They're moving into farmlands and the
big males when they're not running,
they stay up in the mountains and they
use usually formed these like bachelor
records and when they're not running and
when this is happening,
that's where the wolves are.
So the wolves are killing me.
I have friends that live in Idaho and
friends that live in Montana and they're
like,
it's bad.
Like there,
there's a lot of fucking wolves killing
giant elk.
I've been failing in communicating what.
So right now we,
we agree with each other and we're.
We're almost echoing the same sediments.
So that person that doesn't agree with
us that,
that.
I'm Vegetarian Vegan,
I'm a conservationist that,
that looks at us.
She's like,
no,
you guys are hunters.
You can't be conservationist.
Where does the conversation start?
Where's the middle ground where you can
find one where an opportunity to build
rapport and to have a conversation,
have a discussion,
to have maybe even a debate where you
can intellectually talk through your
different perspectives.
I've been failing at this miserably of
late and I've been getting a lot of it.
It's,
it's weird when my social media,
I think I have a lot of conservative
military,
you know,
pro second amendment types that follow
me when that whole entire base is mad at
me,
which is weird.
And then on the other side,
the far left progressive side is looking
at me and be like,
oh,
we hate you too.
So I'm like,
I have now pissed off 95 percent of
people on social media because I'm
trying to find middle ground so we can
talk.
Have you pissed off the conservatives?
Have you done that?
Lance?
Lance Armstrong and I were talking about
gun control after the parklands shooting
in Florida and he asked me,
do you think gun control is a solution?
And I said,
absolutely.
I think gun control can be a massive
solution verbatim.
That's exactly what I said.
Now,
to me,
gun control,
those were words.
Words like,
well regulated militia.
The words in the constitution that the.
That's almost synonymous to me.
Gun Laws.
Also a form of gun control,
just like a well regulated militia.
I think that having good,
safe gun laws,
save lives.
Um,
I don't want to have a felon and Ms. 13
guy,
an illegal immigrant.
Somebody that's been dishonorably
discharged from the military to get
their hands on a gun.
We have laws.
Those are forms of gun control in my
opinion.
But the Conservatives Second Amendment,
if you use the words gun control,
uh,
like I,
I was immediately called Benedict
Arnold.
I'm a trader.
I was uh,
a duff.
I don't even know what a duff is.
That was a reoccurring one.
I think it was the guy from.
I'm
Roger Rabbit,
the guy that would hunt around with the
gun,
but he didn't know how to use the gun
because he always missed Roger Rabbit.
Do you mean bugs bunny?
Yeah.
Bugs bunny step.
Elmer Fudd.
Yeah,
that's where they called fid,
so I all,
I mean hundreds of people and I wouldn't
just,
I'm trying to have a conversation with
Lance Armstrong,
a guy that had never shot a gun at the
time that was against private private
citizens,
really owning guns and he couldn't be
more for gun control,
but I wonder just to talk to him and so
I had no problem using his vernacular,
using,
you know,
the words that he's comfortable with,
like gun control even though to me
that's just gun laws,
that's well regulated.
Militia.
I mean I'm a huge second member
proponent.
I don't think anybody has ever
questioned that until this moment when,
if they just pay attention to you for
five minutes,
all they have dudes is go to your social
media and you know,
is not an anti gun guy.
No guys on the range.
How many days a week?
Six.
Five.
Come on.
Yeah,
like I'm mad that I'm here with you.
I'm not on the range,
you know,
but I said I'll make it up tomorrow.
Yeah,
you are,
you're a gun nut for sure.
For sure.
It's an occupational thing.
Yes.
Like I have no choice.
This is,
this is,
this is what I do know.
If you want to be excellent at your job,
you must be a good.
Yeah.
Uh,
well in that conversation I disavowed
apparently my huge group of Second
Amendment loving people.
I have a theory on that.
I think there's a lot of people that
just looking,
get pissed off and if you say any word
that they decide is a hot button word
like gun control,
they don't care if you've thought it out
and you have a rational perspective on
what you consider gun control.
Like there was a statement that was
released by a group of hunters,
hunters for gun control and they had a
bunch of reasonable reasons why people
shouldn't have a firearm that could get
a firearm currently.
And it all made sense,
but the,
the response to that,
the backlash of it isn't.
It's not debate.
It's like people on that side,
the pro second amendment side,
they're so terrified of any new
regulation and they think that you have
to hold your ground because any slipping
backwards is going to eventually lead to
someone taking your guns away.
I mean,
I,
I do understand the death by a thousand
cuts,
you know,
I,
I think that has always been the
perspective,
you know,
if you look at,
it's not like Adolf Hitler said,
okay,
we're going to kill all the blacks and
all the Jews overnight.
That's not what happened,
right?
It was,
it was over the course of seven,
eight years where he just very
incrementally
change laws.
Okay.
They're not allowed to shop here.
They're not allowed to go here.
Okay.
Now we're gonna move them all into the
same area and very slowly,
not slowly.
And in a matter of five,
six,
seven years,
he started a genocide of an entire
ethnicity.
Um,
and that's that fear.
It's okay.
It's gonna be,
it's gonna be incremental and we're.
And at some point we're going to turn
around and look and be like,
look at all of this freedom that we've
lost.
I think it's the same with during,
right after nine slash 11 when George
Bush,
you know,
the,
the Freedom Act,
uh,
or the Patriot Act,
the Patriot Act,
you know,
like that was one of the largest losses
of privacy that Americans have ever,
ever experienced.
But we were fearful,
we were scared and you know,
like,
I love dangerous freedom,
but overnight we lost a ton of that.
I'm not incrementally just overnight
and,
but the most efficient way is to take it
bit by bit by bit.
So I get that.
Um,
but for Christ sakes,
man,
I'm like,
you can't find somebody that's more of a
proponent of the second one than me,
except apparently on that day when I
pissed off.
So I'm trying to figure out how to have
a conversation.
I can't do it.
I don't think that there are any more of
a second amendment proponents than you
are.
I just think they're ideologically so
rigid in this idea that you can't change
gun laws at all.
And if you think that someone who's on
anti psychotic medication and when I was
bouts of schizophrenia,
you think that person should be allowed
to have guns.
When they hear voices that aren't real,
they,
they see things that aren't really there
had been reported to the FBI a handful
of times.
The sheriff knows about them.
The,
the principal knows about them.
The pro.
Well obviously the problem with that is
someone can decide to report Tim
Kennedy,
they can make up some story.
Tim Kennedy's been acting crazy.
Tim Kennedy's doing these.
Sandy's going to kill my family.
Tim Kennedy's doing this.
Tim Kennedy.
If someone just decides to actively
target you in that way,
they can sort of frame you as some sort
of a crazy person and then use that as
an excuse to go after guns.
I mean this is what people are terrified
of and that is possible.
It is been an objective and there's no
due process on the back side.
Okay.
So if somebody was wrongfully put on a
list or you would not be allowed to buy
a gun,
how do you get off that list?
Right.
How do you,
I don't know,
doing it.
I mean,
as I said,
guy that spends quite a bit of time.
You know what I think hopefully
protecting gun laws and protecting gun
ownership.
I don't even know how to get off that
list.
No,
that's scary.
Probably don't ever get off.
It's like the no fly list.
There's just not a way to not get off
it.
It was the fuck ever gets back on the
flight and I know you were off the list,
but you're back on.
Come on back southwest.
No worries.
Sitting near the window.
No.
Can I?
My beverage service and peanut please.
Yeah.
It's things where there's a left side
and a right side.
If you say something that the left
believes in,
you're a trader and if you see if you're
on the other side of say something,
the right beliefs and you're a trader.
No,
the conversation has to happen in the
middle.
Right?
Does that how?
How,
how?
How do you live?
Conversation with animals has to happen
in the middle.
When you talk you about the consumption
of animals.
You have the hardcore animal rights
activists who don't want anything to
die,
but how do they feel about wolves eating
elk asshole first?
Tear him apart.
Many of you.
Okay with that.
I mean,
are you okay with natural probation?
You are just not okay with humans
predating.
So how do you want to balance out the
population of say,
wild pigs?
Like what do you.
What's your proposal?
They don't have one.
You mean there's not enough resources in
the world to go out and trap them and if
you did trap them when you can do it,
give them.
You got to fix them.
You're going to give him vasectomies.
So we tried to give him to the homeless
but the homeless were eating them in
Texas.
Really?
Why would you not eat wild pig?
I don't.
Delicious Texas wild pigs.
Pretty.
Is it funky?
It's pretty funky.
Really isn't how you just.
How you take care of it?
Well you have to take care of it.
That's the thing is as these are swamp
living.
Oh right,
right,
right.
Rough.
Pretty nasty things.
So there was a period of time where we
could go and during the eradication
we're trying to curb the ever growing
population.
Um,
if you shot x number,
you could bring maybe a fat Sao in and
to the food shelter and they'd have a
butcher and then they tried to serve it
and they're like,
eh,
nobody was eating it.
So then we tried that for about six
months and then they said,
forget it.
We're just wasting money.
Trying to is just so goofy,
goofy world we live in where people who
are starving or picky,
picky.
I don't want that wild pig.
Well maybe,
I mean in their defense maybe he's just
really poorly handled and by the time
they get it it's tainted.
It smells bad and no,
no.
I mean it's entirely possible that
somebody fucked it up along the way.
They don't treat wild pigs in Texas.
Like you would treat like a deer that
you shot,
that you hunted down,
took a long time to track and you had
to,
you know,
get into perfect position and you
cherish that meat.
Wild pigs are shooting them out of
helicopters.
I mean,
you,
I'm sure you've seen those Ted nugent
videos.
Oh yeah,
I do it if you do that.
I do.
Hello hunting.
Yeah,
there'll be farmed.
So a farm in,
let's say central Texas,
north of Austin,
south of Dallas,
they're losing 10 to 15 percent of their
agriculture every single year to wild
pigs and millions of dollars.
So if you have a $10,000,000 ranch,
you're losing one and a half million
dollars to wild pigs.
Wild pigs.
Yeah.
And there's not a lot of profit in,
in,
in being a farmer.
So one and a half million dollars is a
lot of money to these guys and not.
On the flip side,
you have a bunch of.
I'm using hunters,
guys that are coming to because it's
sport fun.
I mean there's not,
there's not much fair game here.
There's not stocking these animals.
It's thermals,
it's white lights off jeeps.
It's any way you can imagine to try to
kill these things and we're not even
making a dent in how fast these things
are breeding.
Yeah.
You know,
they,
the,
the sow can have at the age of one.
It could start having three or four
litters a year.
We get six months.
Oh,
it's crazy.
I think they can start breeding at six
months and they're having multiple
litters a year and each litter can have
six to pigs.
Yeah,
we're done.
If there's zombies where it's over,
it's over.
Well,
if they were predators,
I mean,
imagine if these things were like wolves
spread like that.
Oh,
I bet you have.
Yeah.
You'll know how tim goes to sleep at
night.
You just nailed it,
Joe.
You got it.
I mean,
could you imagine if wolves were doing
that?
If there were that many wolves and they
were just roaming through the
countryside packs of a thousand dollars
of erection now.
Whew.
Yup.
Curb it.
Pull it back,
pull back.
Use your mind.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean that,
that conversation is the conversation
where the vegans run into an ideological
wall,
like what do you would you say about
that?
You want to just let live and let be.
Well,
you're not going to have any vegan food
because they eat vegan food.
Okay.
You're not gonna have any food.
The pigs are gonna.
Eat All your food unless you're growing
your own food,
and then what are you going to do with
the pigs?
Break your fences and eat your food.
You don't have any food left or they
break your fences.
They do break your.
Break your everything.
They,
they are big and they're powerful
creatures and they decimate ground
nesting birds.
Anything that's small.
I mean there's,
there's some videos that we have from
Texas.
Have A,
a big boar running away with an access
to your font and it's mouth.
I mean,
they eat everything they can.
It's their,
they're monsters and they're delicious.
Filling or know about Texas ones.
I'll never had eight,
eight.
I've eaten a couple of California ones.
They were fantastic.
Yep.
My Dad,
you know,
he's in Monterey County.
He,
uh,
he has his pig trough pig pond and he
has a herd of pigs that come every
night.
And the,
I mean,
it's almost like a visceral response for
me to watch my dad drive down in his
four wheeler and feed these things where
I'm like,
oh no god,
why does he feed him?
Because he loves them.
He elk come through there,
you know,
like he has truly lt got wonder since
his property and so he has a bunch of
these wild pigs and so he and his,
my mom,
they sit on the porch and they watched
the wild animals and deer and it's kind
of cool,
super cool.
But then like the texting and he's like,
I don't want to just get rid of all of
those things.
They're bombing nation.
Missouri has an interesting take on it.
They're,
they're making hunting them illegal and
the reason why they're making hunting
them illegal is because people are
bringing them into areas and releasing
them in public land so that they can
hunt these wild pigs and the recognizing
this.
So what they've done to,
to curb the desire for people to do that
is,
first of all,
they're trapping them instead of running
down down with dogs or shooting them and
they find by trapping.
Um,
there's a great podcast that Steve
Rinella,
he has the mediator podcast.
It's a great podcast,
but he had a guy who is a wild pick,
wild pig eradication expert from
Missouri.
He works for the Department of fish and
wildlife down there and uh,
or a,
I guess they call it fishing game down
there for California,
they call it fish and wildlife,
but they're,
um,
they've used these traps.
They,
they can get as many as 63 pigs at a
time and he's like,
if we tried to shoot 63 pigs,
it would take forever to do that.
So they're using these large scale
traps,
catching these and
you know,
they're just killing them and the way
they're doing their,
they're like,
get a lot of backlash from hunters
because the hunters like,
well,
why don't you just let us hunt them to
say no,
we want to get rid of all of them.
These are a dangerous invasive species.
You guys want to keep something around
for fun,
but you're not going to manage the
population correctly.
You really can't.
Yeah.
So they're just,
they're on an eradication bend down
there.
Yeah,
I'd love to see how that works.
They're apparently doing a really good
job in keeping them from spreading into
new areas of public land.
Like they'll get a notification,
someone will say,
hey,
we saw sow and two baby piglets in this
one area,
and they will just go there immediately
and just track those things down and try
to kill him.
The areas where populations are clearly
established that trying to get them from
spreading.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's huge industry too though.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean hunting in general,
we're talking billions and billions of
dollars and you know,
whether your trophy hunting in in Africa
and your,
your pain,
a few hundred thousand dollars for water
buffalo or you know,
you're going in,
you know,
just getting some
blessed balk or an impala and you're
still paying $10,000.
The flight,
the donating the food to the village,
the trophy,
the trophy fee,
the processing,
then the shipping.
And we're the gun itself,
the ammo pain for the Pah,
pain for the guide,
pain for the tracker,
that that's all real real money.
And then on even on the local American
side,
deer hunting,
elk hunting,
pig hunting,
still billion dollar industry.
And uh,
that money directly goes back to habitat
protection conservation.
Not,
not,
not in like incremental percentages,
massive portions of that money.
Yeah.
It's a Sigmund
Robert's act,
right?
It's like,
what is it?
Eleven percent Jamie.
See if you could find that they,
I think they established that in the
thirties and this was uh,
in response to,
you know,
what Teddy Roosevelt did when they were
trying to keep large swaths of public
land available for people to recreate on
and then try to bring back populations
of these animals that needed funds to do
that because market hunting,
people think it was like just hunters
have decimated the population sort of,
but market hunting,
it was hunting wild animals for people
to eat,
which is now illegal.
You can't just go shoot a bunch of deer
and then sell it to people.
It's illegal and one of the reasons why
it's illegals,
they wanted to stop market hunting.
So they take all this money,
which I believe is 11 percent.
Is it 11 percent?
Eleven percent of all the money from
hunting supplies,
gear,
guns,
all that shit.
All of it goes towards conservation.
That turns out to be billions and
billions of dollars a year.
Yeah,
and that's.
That's what keeps the protection.
Here it goes right here.
Okay.
The ninth,
early 19 hundreds marine wildlife
species are disappearing or declining.
The firearms and ammunition industry
asked Congress to impose an excise tax.
I mean,
that is amazing.
They asked to impose this tax on the
sale of firearms and ammunition to help
fund wildlife conservation in the United
States.
The Pittman Robertson Act passed in 1937
known as the federal aid and wildlife
restoration.
So this is.
This is how wetlands get preserved.
Wildlife Habitat.
I'm like a traveling corridors for mule
deer.
How they keep them from getting
developed.
All that stuff is through conservation
money that comes from hunting.
The difference between the amount of
money that comes from hunting and
conservation acts that gets donated to
preserve wildlife versus animal rights
groups is so stunning.
You can't even count.
I mean,
there's like not even pennies on the
dollar,
nothing.
It's like they don't donate.
I mean,
some people donate a few dollars here or
there to things,
but the,
the vast majority of the money comes
from hunters,
which creates this really confusing
place for a lot of people.
That's the middle ground killing
animals.
That's,
that's ended up being like the middle
ground conversation that nobody will
actually have the conversation about
Africa to right.
That those animals,
when you let people hunt them,
they're worth a lot more than if you
just let the poachers come in and
protect them.
But the moment that the hunters go away,
they disappear.
But the animal rights activists and the
vegans were like us to move past that
and get to the point where we don't kill
animals at all.
And if you eat animals,
you get it from a lab.
It's not impossible,
but it's go to Africa,
it's fucking hot in Africa.
It's probably impossible unless some
massive evolution happens with
consciousness and people just stop being
people.
Yeah.
So Limpopo,
which is north of South Africa,
right on the Botswana border,
um,
they kinda like gave this world of
trying to 90 percent of the exact right
location,
but they,
they,
they outlawed the hunting of some
specific wild game and the farmers that
have had them just kind of,
okay,
we're just gonna we're just going to let
them go because you're not worth
anything to us.
All of their animals disappeared in a
year.
Poached.
That's crazy.
In a year.
One year all of them were gone,
just disappeared.
Um,
so the intent was,
okay,
these,
these are nearing endangered,
so we're gonna allow people to Hump
them.
Uh,
and then they went from endangered to
almost endangered to absolutely
endangered the critically because nobody
was protecting them because there are no
hunters.
That one too did
them.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard for people to wrap their head
around because it's so messy.
It's not a clean issue.
It's so messy.
And you see some fat slob holding his
rifle over a lion and you go,
there's no way in nature this fat fuck
should be able to shoot that lion and
just,
you know,
and mounted on his wall.
There's a photo that I got off the
Internet of a guy.
He looks like he's about 500 pounds,
let me just overflowing with gluttony
just.
And he's got a rifle and there's a
deadline there.
And I'm like,
okay,
does every,
this is everything that's wrong with
hunting because he's not going to eat
that lion.
Like why did he go over there to shoot
that line?
It's one thing if that line was like
hunting,
his family are interfering with his
cattle business and no,
no,
no.
That guy flew over there.
He wattled over to the bike,
the bog pod,
rest of the rifle down and pulled the
trigger on one of the biggest apex
predators on the planet.
Everybody should have a problem with
that.
It's fucking weird.
It's weird.
But now here's the contradiction.
If those animals aren't worth money for
people to hunt,
then what happens is they will happens
in Zimbabwe.
They just kill hundreds of them because
they're,
there's too many of them now because
people aren't hunting them,
so they're decimating the Angelo
population,
so they have to curb the lions.
So instead of getting $50,000 or
$100,000 a lion from a hunter,
which goes to the villagers,
goes to conservation NGOs to hire
professional hunters.
Now they get nothing and they have to
pay someone to go and shoot these lines
and they should,
all of them should all have issued all
of them.
And you're like,
well,
this sucks.
This is not good.
None of this shit.
This ain't good both ways.
Not good to lose that fat guy standing
over a line.
And it's not good to look at these,
you know,
these government people shooting 200
lions and just dumping them into a hole
somewhere.
The whole thing's a mess.
That's Africa.
Here we try to do the right thing.
Um,
or you know,
if you're going to get a,
if you're gonna,
get a bear tag from Colorado or are you
going to bear tag from New Mexico for
that tag to be issued?
They measured the amount of food that's
in each district and then you're,
they're going to issue six tags because
there's enough food to.
There's 12 bears there,
but there's only enough food to feel to
feed six of them,
so they're going to issue six tags that
or all 12 of them might starve to death
or the majority of them,
so they're going to issue and you can go
and buy your six tags.
That leaves six animals in that,
in that area,
in that region.
They are able to hunt your pain for that
tech.
A lot of money.
Sometimes if you're out of state,
you know you're paying a few hundred
dollars,
five,
six,
$700,
flights,
hotels.
It's for a bear and it adds up.
It adds up
is up,
but you know,
understand the mindset of people that
don't want any of this to happen.
I do understand that,
but I do think that they don't
understand nature.
I really don't think they understand
that this is the best death these
animals will ever experience and they're
not going to live forever in the wild
and the wild.
They're going to be torn apart by
something bigger than that.
That's just how it goes 100 percent of
the time.
Or they freeze to death or they starve
to death
or they're starving.
They walked out onto the road and try to
find some food in the town they get hit
by a semi truck.
Yeah,
that sounds good.
Yeah.
And if I have a buddy who lives in Iowa
and when you drive in his neighborhood
at night,
you'd better go 35 miles an hour because
those fuckers just darting out in front
of the street,
left and right.
They're everywhere.
And you know,
what's the,
what's the solution?
Don't drive cars.
Drive your bike everywhere man.
Well,
okay,
good luck with that.
Yeah,
I get it.
I get where those people are coming
from.
They're coming from a place of
compassion,
but it becomes very culty and it becomes
very,
very team oriented.
Their team Vegan and
there's like words were circling back
were,
you know,
when you're trying to have that middle
ground,
that discussion,
that conversation.
Um,
there's like this pre assigned talking
points.
Yeah.
Where everybody from every respect of
side mixed essentially the same
arguments and you're just regurgitating
what you've heard other people say,
but there's no new thoughts is new and
there's no one taking a step to either
side like,
okay,
do you want maybe maybe there's
something I'm not seeing here.
Let me look at it from this perspective
or vice versa.
Where this side,
the hunters like,
no,
no you,
you stupid snowflake,
you know,
go get your starbucks latte with soy
milk and.
But they're never looking at it from
anything new right there.
They're just regurgitating their talking
points.
Like when you said gun control and
people freaked out,
freaked out because I didn't stay to the
script and there's a script.
I mean if you,
if you pull up my,
my,
any of my social,
you will see that.
Oh you what you should've said was or
hey,
you know,
shall not be infringed upon.
Yeah man,
I got it.
Yeah.
Shall not be infringed upon and believe
it to death.
Have you fought for it?
Have you bled for it?
You've been blown up for it.
You can try it.
I have,
you know,
I really believe in this shit but I
didn't stay to the script and then I get
murdered by both sides.
So then what,
how do we,
I mean,
you do a pretty good job,
so teach me Joe,
how do you bring people in to have
a talk?
There's got to be a lot of people that
disagree with you and say I do a
terrible job that I repeat the same
things over and over again and I agree
with them too,
for for a certain amount of the
conversations like this one.
I mean we,
I've had this conversation about
conservation and animals a hundred
times,
but I think it's worth having 100 more
because I think it's an important that
if someone is listening to this podcast
and they didn't understand how it all
works and they didn't understand that
people who hunt and eat meat,
they're not monsters.
They're not evil people,
just like people who eat grain aren't
monsters because you counselee disregard
the lives of mice and rats,
all the things they get ground up and
combines and bunnies like if you buy
grain,
large scale agriculture is bad,
period.
It's bad in terms of factory farming,
but it's also bad in terms of growing
food.
If you grow a thousand acres of corn,
you are absolutely displacing wildlife
and when that stuff gets harvest,
you see vultures fly over those fields
and there's a reason.
It's because there's a bunch of dead
things.
In fact,
more dead lives,
more dead lives occur in a pound of
grain than occur in a pound of beef
because if you think that a cow is more
valuable than a bunny because it's
larger,
like you've got some weird thing going
on in your own head.
Can you tell me how to balance the soles
worth on box
and how'd you feel about insects?
Because they are a large scale poisoning
those fucking insects and you know it.
Everybody knows and they're grinding
those fuckers up with earth worms and
mice
and gophers and chipmunks and anything
else that gets stuck in those wheels.
That is just how large scale agriculture
works,
so unless you have some isolated farm
where everything is fenced in and you
only have,
you know,
a certain amount of acreage and that
farm feeds you will you are Karma free
and congratulations to you.
You figured out how to do it.
But most of us who buy pasta,
if you go and buy bread in the store,
you're paying someone who's killed a
large amount of living things in order
to harvest that grain.
That's just a fact.
It's just a fact and it's an
inconvenient fact that they like to look
at with blinders on because they,
you know,
like Hashtag cruelty free not to that
fucking bunny rabbit that's a part of
your tofu because this is,
this is what's really going on.
I mean,
a good part of the b vitamin B that a
lot of vegans get is from ground up bugs
that's ground up into their grain and
ground up into their vegetables.
I mean,
this is you,
this is just,
you can't get away around that.
No,
I mean if you are being real,
if you're not,
if you're being real.
Yeah,
and that maybe that's the problem in the
first place is nobody is going to have
the courage to come into that middle
ground and let,
let go of all of their baggage and all
of their
bullshit and just cool with eating bugs.
You should eat crickets.
Get cricket meal,
eat cricket proteins.
Fucking good for you.
If you don't want to eat animals,
you're like,
I'm just not into anything that's warm.
Okay.
I have a friend who only eats fish and I
go,
why?
He goes,
fish don't even take care of their
babies.
I was like,
Ooh.
Good point.
That is a good point.
Fuck those fish fishery.
Yummy too.
He's like,
I don't want to kill a mammal.
He goes,
I don't want to eat a mammo.
He's like,
mammals take care of their babies.
The babies milk from there.
There are others.
I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
My wife has a pescatarian for awhile.
Um,
that didn't,
that didn't last.
It's just not the best source source of
nutrients.
Well,
it was when she's pregnant and the
doctor's like,
alright,
so you're 90 pounds and uh,
I need you to put on like 20 more pounds
really fast and you're not going to do
it.
Eating halibut.
Yeah.
So her iron was low.
Iron b12.
I mean all the fat soluble vitamins that
are very difficult to get some grants.
They're very good.
Yeah.
It's a company called.
Well,
they changed their name.
They used to be called off with the Ergo
depot,
another called fully and this is called
the Pisco.
It's the best ergonomic chair.
I fucking love these things.
I sit in these things hours a day.
My back
bothers me.
I,
I really can't sit for very long periods
of time on my desk at home.
My reloading station.
It's all standing height or one of those
standing desk guys.
Yup.
I'll even take a medicine ball,
like the balance balls and um,
I'll get on my knees on it and I'll just
balance.
Oh,
that's a good move.
Yeah.
It feels good and it's good.
But his type type of your core strong,
it's less of the core and it's more um,
I like a seven year old brain,
you know,
that if,
if I'm,
I'm not doing a lot of things at once,
I just get distracted so I just do lots
of things at once,
like having to balance on a ball so I
don't smash my face into the desk and
knock myself out while I'm reloading
ammunition.
And playing with explosives like that is
a perfect recipe for me to be successful
at reloading bullets.
You reload explosive as well as bullets?
No,
no.
So.
Oh well I'm gunpowder isn't explosive.
Right?
Right,
right.
I thought you meant like grenades and
shit to.
No,
I will take a,
like if we are going to go do so
tomorrow I'm playing with the Dutch
special forces at roughly peak ranch in
Austin,
Texas and we are going to set up a bunch
of booby traps for them when they come
in to do their,
like their final culmination hit the
full mission profile.
So they're going to spend all day
planning and they're going to figure out
how they're going to walk through the
woods and not get caught and I'm
essentially the terrorists that they're
going to try and come kill 'em.
But I'm a really good terrorist.
So how do you guys keep from actually
killing each other when you're doing
this?
Oh,
they're using,
um,
simunitions.
So they're there.
They use a real guns with different
bolts that shoot paintballs
yeah.
And then the feet per second of these
paint balls flying.
800.
Okay.
It still stings like a motherfucker.
I'm still wearing like hockey glasses,
you know,
like the,
our snowboard glasses ever catch one in
the mouth.
Yeah.
I have a friend that has like a tattoo
on his lip from the,
from the paint.
Oh,
wonderful.
Yeah.
And it just went like,
it's all the way to the flesh,
like it won't come out.
And he's like a chunk of pink and his
lip for.
I offered to cut it out.
He said no,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I'm really good with a knife,
so I bet you are.
Yeah.
Dan,
if you're listening to right now,
let me cut that out of your face.
It makes them unique.
Is Unique.
What is finding Hitler all about?
Um,
this is a show that you're on and it's
on a one.
Is that what's on?
Yeah.
Amy Is the parent network.
It airs on history channel and we just
had our third season that just finished
airing.
What's the thought process behind this
is legit because a lot of people are
like finding Hitler.
Get the fuck out of here.
They found Hitler.
He died.
Yeah.
I mean not really.
We don't know that that's the,
that's this isn't like ancient aliens.
This is whee they declassified a bunch
of documents.
They,
both the Israelis and the British and
the Germans and Americans in the past 20
years have been consistently
declassified documents and there were a
bunch of specifically FBI documents that
we were spending millions and millions
of dollars actively searching for Hitler
after the war as was.
Yeah,
like millions of dollars.
Like hoover was like,
no,
no.
Send more FBI agents to South America
and to North Africa.
Go to the canary,
go to Spain,
trying to find out where this guy went,
tons of real FBI documents with real
leads,
with real informance some hand or some
first I accounts saying that they
physically.
So anyways,
that's the show is us trying to find
out,
sift through reality.
And I'm the fiction of the,
the allure,
the mist,
the mystery of that asshole.
So what's the official story?
The official story is that he killed
himself right now.
Killed themself in the bunker with David
Braun.
Yep.
And is there any photographic evidence
of his death or anything?
So what?
The Russians got the body and they got
his school.
Um,
and when they brought it back to Moscow,
nobody has ever been able to
independently verify who and what this
body is.
They let one genetic tests occur and the
body with the bullet holes that they
said was Hitler and have said.
And that's the narrative.
That's a story.
That's the,
all the eyewitness accounts that are in
even in the vicinity of collaborating
with each other.
Um,
and cooperating each other's testimony,
like the closest version because none of
it seems to be very accurate.
Is that okay?
Here's Hitler school.
And when they did the genetic testing,
it's that of a 35 year old woman.
So like,
oh,
well this isn't Hitler.
But they have said for the past 80 years
that this is Hitler.
So,
okay,
first before we start throwing stones at
Russia,
let's go back to 1945.
April Ma in Berlin,
you have the allies coming in,
wrecking shop,
dropping bombs,
blowing everything up.
They can in every single which way you
have the Russians coming from the
opposite direction.
They don't even have enough guns to arm
all their soldiers.
So if they have 200 guys that are
200,000 guys,
they have 100,000 guns that the guy in
front of you dies.
You just pick up his gun.
That's what's happening in April of 1945
in Berlin.
So the noose is tightening.
There is no,
it is chaos.
Anarchy pandemonium.
This,
I mean you couldn't.
This is hell on earth is Berlin.
Nineteen 45.
So I don't know if you could get a real
story,
a real.
The way that we do it now,
where we have,
you know,
this forensic experts that come in and
document everything and we look at all
the different testimonies.
Say this is this exactly how.
It's just not,
it's not CSI.
This is 1945 Berlin.
It's crazy.
So,
so there's,
there was no like absolute proof.
No.
And a lot of Nazis did escape and go to
South America.
America,
the majority of anyone with power,
the Nuremberg trials a,
we're not a witch hunt,
but it was too close a chapter so we
could start moving forward with
communism.
That's what it was.
The threat of fascism,
the threat of Hitler,
that the threat of killing all the Jews,
the threat of world domination by the
Nazis that threat's gone.
What's the next threat?
Communism.
So that had to be a closed chapter of
our history.
So we could focus our resources and our
efforts to what inevitably was going to.
I mean the wall goes up.
We have east and West Berlin,
you know,
we're already looking at Korea.
I mean,
this,
this happens almost overnight,
no one patents like no,
no homies,
we need to go all the way to Matt
Moscow.
This is not the end of our war.
And we didn't listen to him.
Um,
we then had been fighting communism for
the past 75 years.
So the ones with power that went to
South America,
I know a bunch of them went to
Argentina.
Uh,
they think,
uh,
they went to Honduras and a few other
places where,
where do they think they wound up?
So what you had in South America,
both Chile and Argentina,
back to back head fascist regimes.
You had a parone who was part of the
Nazi party starting all the way back
into the mid thirties.
He's the president of Argentina.
So the Red Cross,
um,
they were facilitate.
There was about three different rat
lines that guys were able to
successfully get out of Europe,
into South America.
Um,
and these are,
there's no question that we're talking
thousands,
if not tens of thousands of high ranking
Nazis made it there.
Tens of thousands,
tens of thousands.
And I'm not talking like little
soldiers.
I'm talking high ranking Nazis officers
got guys like Joseph Mengele and Adolf
Eichmann.
I mean,
these are the most disgusting,
despicable humans to exist at the time.
If Hill,
if Hitler is dead,
Joseph Mengele is the guy that would
take syringes full of blue ink and
inject them and you have blue eyes,
Joe,
or you have brown eyes.
Let me see if I can make them blue and
then take twins and start torturing them
to see if one would feel the pain.
That's Josef Mengele.
I mean,
that's the guy that then in South
America was helping.
Um,
high ranking Argentinians have abortions
and he set up,
um,
have you seen the movie Colonia about
Colonia Dignity?
Dad,
which has that,
if you're listening right now,
almost warn you not to google it because
it is it.
It was a torture camp that was started
by Joseph Shaffer,
a Nazi and Joseph Mengele the doctor of
death that escaped trial in Nuremberg
and made it.
I'm at the behest of parone into
Argentina.
He sat at the hospital at Colonia
dignity that,
which was another safe house,
safe haven for more Nazis in South
America.
Go to my ehr and David,
Ben Gurion,
the presidents of Israel.
Um,
they,
they took the gloves off and they were
just sending assassins to try to find
these people and killed them.
Um,
but what you got in South America were
isolated German only communities.
You could go into Bariloche,
Argentina,
and you know,
I'd be like,
what else is Migos?
And they're like,
Guten Morgen.
I'm like,
Oh yeah.
I mean I met.
Good morning.
Yeah,
sorry.
It's 2017,
right?
I thought we spoke Spanish.
So in 2017 you were there and they were
speaking German.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Why I'm,
I don't look very.
I might look more European than we do
show is just them seeing me walking down
the street and be like,
wow.
And there's tons of communities.
I mean if you go to Colonia digged the
data which is now called via Bavaria,
the Bavarian village,
it is a only German in the center of
Chile,
in the mountains of Chile.
Like you,
there's no Spanish being spoken there.
It is exclusively German and these are
descendants of Nazis.
He powerful Nazis.
Holy Shit.
And this is going on right now.
And what are these communities like?
I mean,
what's their ideology or they.
they're pretty white.
Yeah.
What are they like?
Are they,
do they espouse Nazi values are not
openly so colonia dignity dad.
Uh,
if you look the second generation,
there's a bunch of.
So it was a huge problem for Chile that
they tried to hide for years and they,
they got so much power from the
torturing that they did at Colonia dicta
dad on a whole bunch of other high
ranking South American dictators that
they're almost untouchable.
And this,
this is,
I mean,
you,
you'd blow your mind if you look into
this jail,
you,
you'd love it.
But I'm the second generation,
the kids,
the grandkids,
sometimes they're even more fanatical
than the original generation.
Have you ever seen this where like if
somebody is away from,
like when you travel abroad,
man,
it's so cool to like get into the
culture and get into the food and get
into the,
like you're dancing this style and you
love the flag and you're like,
oh,
I'm gonna go to a soccer game.
Because we don't go to soccer games in
America that I'm going,
but then maybe after like two months you
kind of miss home,
you know,
and then like a year,
like you really miss home and then 10
years like you really,
really miss home and you see the same
thing in the United States where it's
not really a perfect assimilation.
It's not the melting pot where you see
generations that are espousing to be
more like their ethnic heritage than
they are American,
you know,
they're flying the Irish flag and like
I'm,
I'm Irish,
I'm what's just times a thousand with
these communities because they're
exclusively German.
Oh yeah.
It's pretty cool.
Kind of weird.
So exclusively German and really missing
home.
Yeah.
So in the years later,
the second generations I was talking
about,
um,
some of them came to the United States
and were high ranking white supremacists
that are now in jail,
in prison for their racial crimes.
And they came out of South America.
They came out of Colonia dignity.
Dad that came out of low che.
They came out of that,
came out of Ms Dot Joan as they came out
of.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So that's the show hunting.
Hitler
fucking a man to spread.
How many people are we talking about?
All told in South America that can come
out of this.
I mean tens of thousands went there,
but how many German communities and
what?
How big are they?
We maybe have 50 German communities.
Fifty fifth.
How many people?
If you had to guess,
a few hundred thousand.
Holy Shit.
Few hundred thousand descendants of
Nazis.
Wow.
Yeah.
And me.
And it's weird when you walk into
somebody's parlor and it's like you're
stepping back in time into Europe.
Like I'm walking in,
it's 2017 and I'm walking in Buenos
Aires,
Argentina into somebody's parlor and all
of the tile is European and all of the
style and all the art is very German.
You know,
we have like deers and know not,
not like red stags of what we're talking
German,
everything.
Things that Hitler loved and that's the
style.
That's everything.
And then they come out and like with
white gloves,
they're holding their GRANDPA,
their grandfather's a memory box and
inside of it or his war medals from,
you know,
when he was in the ss or when he was.
And it is the respect the.
I don't even know the difference.
Yeah.
I mean it's like whoa.
Like it's the,
it's like this is a gift from the pope
that they're holding their hands.
White gloves.
No,
I can't for.
First of all,
tim can't touch it.
That's.
But I can appreciate it.
And then they tell me the story of every
single one of these things and how he
got there and how he then went and
worked for the miniseries.
News can't touch anything.
No,
they wouldn't know because I come,
you'll,
you're dirty,
dirty,
dirty American America.
He's goes to Brown.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
So we followed the first two seasons.
It was really just unraveling the rumors
of what happened to Hitler.
The third season was my favorite because
I actually got to do real work.
They said,
okay,
I got to the second season I got to
bring in more special forces.
Guys.
I'm a CIA targeter Nadia who helped my
unit kill Zarqawi in 2006 that this is
the team that is now looking at real
evidence trying to figure out,
okay,
how did we find Bin Ladin?
How do we find the car is our county.
We looked at their associates and we
looked at how they move.
We looked at how they communicated,
we looked at what routes they were using
to get to and from places,
and then we just started tightening the
noose and that's exactly what we did in
this third season was,
okay,
let's start following the Adolf
eichmanns.
Let's start following the Josef Mengele
and let's start following the scores and
skis.
Hitler's personal bodyguard,
that was a colonel in the ss that went
onto work for everybody after the war
fighting.
I mean fascists do not like communists.
So this guy was working for everybody to
include the CIA fighting fascism and
South America are fighting communism as
a fascist in South America in the
fifties,
sixties,
and seventies.
Creepy stuff.
Yeah.
So,
so haunting Hiller.
Are there any legitimate eye witness
accounts of Hitler in South America or
potentially legitimate?
You?
Absolutely.
Potentially.
Whoa.
Yep.
I witnessed counts.
I saw him get off a boat.
I saw him meet here and if it was just
some person saying it,
it's almost meaningless.
Right?
But if you look at the context of who
this person is,
the wealth that they have that they
shouldn't have and I can,
can you explain how you got so rich and
two generations,
you know,
like,
okay,
your grandpa got here from Germany in
1946.
That's weird.
Um,
and he,
he,
he's on a legitimate visa with an
Argentinian passport,
also weird.
Um,
and now he's a war refugee that's now
worth millions of dollars.
How does this,
how does this work?
So,
but people.
And then this is the hard part.
People want to be connected to
significant events and,
and especially in small rural areas of
the world,
developing areas like they want their.
So nothing there so little happening.
They want to be attached to something
massive.
And like the fact that they saw you boat
land on this beach and the pop,
the hatch opened and you know,
this,
these cars were sitting there and they
were doing morse code and this guy gets
off and he had this little mustache.
You're like,
W for u boats can't beach.
That's not how that works.
But you know what they're trying to do.
They just want to be connected.
Yeah.
So,
and now we're removed 70 to 80 years
from the facts.
It has been painful to try to use real
science,
real investigative tools to try to sift
through
this lore.
You know?
What do you think happened?
I mean,
you've been,
you've been studying this for how long
now?
Three years.
If you had to guess,
if you had like a million bucks,
you've got to put it on one side or
another.
Did he go there?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
I would say,
man,
it's that.
That's the first time I've ever said it
flat out like that.
What would I want to say is the way
history is written is wrong.
That that's,
that's clear.
There's no way that we can say he died
on this day,
this is what happened.
Here is his body.
And that's what a physical proof is.
For sure.
The woman that had,
they were saying was Hitler is
definitely not Hitler.
He's absolutely.
That's a.
So they don't have Hitler's body.
So then our other option was kate,
is it ava?
Brahms did.
He just grabbed the wrong body.
Right.
So there are still descendants of,
of eva and we tried to have them allow
us to do it.
Then we tried to go through like,
um,
and they can get DNA off of the skull.
Just meat on it.
It's like a tooth.
Yeah.
And um,
but they wouldn't consent to it.
So then we tried to.
Do you know where people have like the
tree,
they're ethnic treat.
What are those websites called?
Twenty three in me.
Yeah.
There's like a bunch of them.
We try to go that route,
but
that wouldn't consent to it.
Nope.
The Eva Braun's family,
they just want it gone.
They just don't want.
Yeah,
there are super pissed that we even
found them,
I'm sure.
Which was hard.
Which is really hard.
Hold them down and get them to spit in
the bucket.
Yeah,
the uh,
I know,
I mean,
or pull the trash and pull stuff out of
there.
Now it was totally not.
Do that.
Definitely not do that.
Um,
but I mean that's how they caught the
golden state killer,
right?
It was off a cigarette.
But yeah,
they got dna off a cigarette butt.
So history is wrong for it to be black
and white like that and fuck man.
And if,
and again,
if you go back to 1945,
um,
we needed scientists.
We needed every single German,
electrical engineer,
mechanical engineer,
aerospace.
Anything.
You're on the [inaudible] program,
you know,
any,
we will,
all of you.
Because now it's a race.
It's a race.
We have the bomb,
now we need delivery systems.
Now we need to get to the moon.
Now we need to know like all of those
things are real time.
It's a war,
a war of dollars and a wharf science.
And um,
we got all those scientists.
The Russians didn't.
Well they got some,
some not very many.
Operation paperclip was what
brought over the what?
Wernher von Braun,
who was,
when you talk to Jews that were in
Berlin during the time that Wernher von
Braun was running his rocket program
there,
he would hang the five slowest Jews in
front of the rocket factory in Berlin.
Just to give everybody motivation to
work harder.
Yeah.
It's.
The Simon Wiesenthal Center said that if
Wernher von Braun was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes
against humanity.
He was a Nazi,
straight up Nazi and people there's
apologist that say,
no,
no.
He was a scientist.
He was forced into doing that.
Like that's like,
okay,
he's a Nazi.
There's photographs of him wearing Nazi
garb hanging out with Nazis.
He,
his rocket factory killed Jews like this
is.
These are all undeniable
except the war ends and they're not.
Not.
That's not how that works.
Exactly,
but they were.
They were forgiven
because they came over and contributed
to our rocket program.
Not that I'm not that good of a human.
I don't have that in me.
I don't have that.
Like,
okay,
you're forgiven because they wanted to
beat the Russians and they knew the
Russians got a bunch of them to know,
you know,
the Russians got a bunch of them for
their rocket propelled.
The Egyptians did.
The Egyptians were trying to create a
delivery system to drop bombs into
Israel.
And then Ben Gurion started having these
Nazi scientists tried to have them
assassinated.
They were mailing the facade was,
how are you familiar with this facade
was mailing package bombs into Egypt and
throughout Europe trying to kill these,
these German scientists.
And they were all German Nazi rocket
guys that were working for Egypt,
Egypt and Egypt and wanting to go blow
Israel.
This is into the sixties.
So they're still trying to find ways to
kill the Jews and they're like,
oh yeah,
we'll go work for you.
Egypt,
you know,
so it sounds crazy is how fucking
technologically advanced that Germans
were so far ahead of us.
It's so amazing.
And to this day you drive a bmw and you
go,
Whoa,
on human fuckers are on point.
Yeah.
Chevy Malibu right now.
And I'm like,
you drive a corvette,
get a new corvette.
They're pretty fucking bad ass.
It's on what you buy.
But I mean,
I mean there's German engineering in the
eighties is fucking phenomenal.
I mean if you drove a German car for the
19 eighties and an American car from the
eighties,
it's like there's no comparison.
Now I have a 1991 porsche and it's a
fucking piece of engineering man.
It's a marvel of engineering.
It's not fast like a modern car.
But when you compare like the build
quality and how they constructed it and
how it's put together in comparison to
a.
I'll fucking dodge Daytona from 1990.
That's a hunk of shit.
Nobody wants one of those today.
Well,
I mean,
unless you're going to build a VB IED
than you want it.
Oh that's the only time you'd.
If you could blow it up again,
it's you.
The way you think is different.
You know,
13 year old child trafficking,
counterfeit money and it's will be.
We'll be in some country and I'll be
walking by and I'll look at a car and be
like,
that would make a great bomb and I swear
to God she would go through my head,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's how the business works.
We'll grow up someday.
So when you're over there in Argentina
and you're meeting with these people and
you know that the descendants of Nazis
and they'll bring out this grandfathers
chest of things and war medals and all
this jazz,
like,
what is this feeling like?
Do you feel like these people got away
with something and then they kind of
did,
but these aren't the people that did it,
but they're the descendants of the
people that did it and they're still
worshiping those people in some way.
Yeah.
I had,
um,
I had a lot of soul searching.
I'm trying to figure out what is the
appropriate thing,
what's the appropriate spots?
What am I seeing?
What am I supposed to be feeling
right now?
And I think I'm a pretty.
I'm exposed person.
Like I'm in tuned with what I feel and
I'm one of the hardest days.
We're in Chile and I interviewed this,
this man and this woman,
and uh,
they are both.
One of them is a second generation.
She was born on a Colonia dignity dad on
this compound as a Nazi.
I'm separated from her parents.
She didn't know who her parents was,
not,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry.
She was brought there at like age three
or four,
but she grew up there and see,
and they're separated from parents who
are parents was her husband,
was a Chilean boy that was local and he
heard about this new hospital that's
built by Dr Mengele and um,
how everybody has food there and he's a
porch lane kid.
So he was able to get onto the compound.
Um,
well the locals and the Germans aren't
supposed to be together.
So he was kind of kept separated.
What?
Because he was local,
they started testing him,
um,
and grow.
It got really violent and disgusting.
By the time he is a teenager,
he's been thrown out of out of windows,
having his bones broken,
being nursed back to health,
being set on fire,
be nurse back to health for like 10,
15 years.
He finally talks his what will be his
future wife into escaping with him and
they sneak out on in a chief's truck
because one of his friends,
when he was a Chilean kid,
grew up to be a police officer in nearby
and he was able to get a letter out to
them and be like,
please come help us.
And they came in and do a health
inspection and they hopped inside of
this cheese cheese truck and they got
away.
So I'm,
I'm talking to this guy and he's telling
me about the things that happened to
them and I'm not going to get into it.
I mean,
but they were the most horrible things
that could happen to a little boy that
you could imagine,
you know,
beyond rape,
beyond being burnt,
alive,
beyond being broken for,
for years and years and years.
And I'm shaking because I,
I,
man,
I'm in Afghanistan and you know,
they threw some acid on some kids and I
found those guys to kill those guys
because that's what you do when you,
when you hurt little kids.
Um,
you know,
I got a soft spot for people that can't
take care of themselves,
that can protect themselves.
I think every real human isn't gonna let
anything weaker them ever get hurt in
front of them.
And so I'm shaking,
listen to the story,
you know,
and I was like,
and I know I have to go back to Colonia
digging dad the next day and put on like
I'm a tourist guy hosting a travel show
and that that's always our disguise to
get in there.
And was like,
Oh,
you know,
this is a beautiful Bavarian village.
You can come here.
That was the,
our little way in and I was just going
to go in and destroy that whole entire
place.
That was my plan.
And the guy's looking at me and he's
like,
I see your anger,
you know?
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm going to go hurt.
All of them.
He's like,
no,
you no more pain.
And I said,
okay,
what do you,
what's going on?
He looks at his wife and he goes,
that's.
She saved me every time that I burned.
Every time that was broken,
it was just love.
That's how I got out.
That's why we're alive today and we're
going to die of old age together with a
woman that I fell in love with on this
colony.
The only thing that matters is love.
And I was like,
God damn,
I like you,
but I still want to go hurt.
All of those people,
you know.
So it's like,
so these people that were doing this to
him,
what was,
what was their objective?
They wanted to understand.
I mean,
so the same test that Joseph Mengele was
doing in Germany in 1943,
he's now doing in Chile in 1953.
He just has a different population to
test.
They're not Jews there,
chalene boys.
And they're strong and they're wirey and
the less food,
they're not like the,
I'm using quotation marks,
the cockroach Jews that you just
couldn't kill,
you know,
these were,
these were young strong browns.
Like these are their words verbatim that
I'm using,
you know?
And he's like,
yeah,
I want to tell your guys' faces out and
stick soldering irons in your ear
because you guys are so evil.
But then I'm the same as them.
So I just really torn.
I didn't know what to do.
I just want to kill them all.
Well,
it's on the worst aspects of human
beings is the desire to hurt people that
are weaker than you and tortured them.
And this is just coming into contact
with that.
And then some guy who has this most
beautiful response to it.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm love saved.
I just want to die.
Oh fuck.
You're a better human than I.
So I never knew how to respond to these
things.
I wanted to.
Every time I'd see a new ss metal or I'd
see this the cross that they won for
valor like crazy.
The equivalent of Medal of honors these
guys have in there.
Parlors are like,
these were Nazis.
You realize your grandpa?
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
Total pride.
Swelling in their chest,
you know,
I was like,
oh no.
Cracking the face dude.
How did Mengele die?
Did he die of old age?
Old Age.
He died on a beach in Brazil.
His Journal was found on the beach in
Brazil.
Mother fucker.
Yeah.
Married a beautiful Brazilian girl.
Wow.
Adolf Eichmann.
He got snatched by,
um,
the,
the massaad in Argentina scores and ski.
He died of old age actually in the 19 in
the sixties.
The Egyptians,
when they're trying to build that rocket
plug program to,
to annihilate the,
a,
to annihilate Israel scores.
NCS started working for the facade,
but he didn't really know it for their
pain.
Him millions of millions of dollars to
hold these parties for what he thought
was the rise of the Fourth Reich.
Whoa.
Yeah.
He was bringing in like,
um,
Mercedes and a crucial,
crucial steel steel crushed,
steal these,
these massive billion dollar
corporations for the time he was hosting
these soirees and talk and having other
high level Nazis that were still alive
come in.
And um,
he was just really being used by the
massage to try to figure out who was
facilitating this Egyptian rocket
program.
So they've just been putting on these
parties to kind of get everybody
together so they could keep tabs on
everybody and figure out who's who.
That's what the facade was doing.
He was doing it with the intent of
making the forthright,
yeah,
rising the Fourth Reich.
So the massage did this and then what
did they do once they figured out who
was who
finally,
they don't like this part because I like
just getting killing bad people.
Um,
they figured out that the,
the,
the big problem with the delivery system
for the Egyptians in their missile
program was the navigation system and
they are trying to hire a whole bunch of
these experts,
um,
to come work for this program.
And they diplomatically kind of went
behind the back and they got all of
this,
this really the only experts in the
world,
they prevented them from going and
traveling to and work for Egypt.
Um,
so they kind of diplomatically ended the
development of delivery system for
their,
their warheads.
So that's how they handled it.
After they poisoned some people and they
sent some mail bombs,
they kidnapped a guy and tortured him
and killed him.
Fuck yeah.
Real,
real torture.
Not,
not fake torture.
It's amazing how few people know about
the Nazi escapees that went to South
America.
It's,
it's amazing how when this comes up,
it's,
it's relatively unknown.
I mean,
your show has done a lot to shed some
light on it.
And I've read some articles about Nazis
that escaped to South America,
but it's not common knowledge.
No.
By design,
I mean when you're down there,
there is a,
there's a shroud of silence.
You,
you,
you're not supposed to talk about these
things.
The,
it takes a long time for me to get an
interview with a guy.
It takes a long time for building
rapport.
I mean,
we're talking like we have some pretty
high level people working with me,
special operations from every single
branch to include the CIA,
Army special forces and we are pulling
out every trick in the book to try to
get these people to talk to us to
include bribing them and the um,
it's hard.
So they,
they still don't talk about it.
To this day.
Did you have to bring in German speaking
people?
Yeah,
a lot of time.
Wow.
I mean,
what can be done?
I mean there's not the same people,
right?
These are people that benefited from the
people that went down there.
So you're talking about like third
generation removed,
but what can be done?
Uh,
the kind of the damage is done,
right?
Yeah.
But that's a lot of damage.
What can be done is the ideas can die.
The ideas of,
of fascism,
the ideas of racism,
the,
those,
those things.
We can kill 'em.
But are those ideas,
are those ideas being fostered in these,
these communities?
Yes.
Yeah,
there are being cultivated.
Yeah.
Because like you experienced it.
I mean,
if I'm a white guy,
white guy walking down the street,
I am,
I am a higher degree than the locals,
you know,
like I can,
I can go and shop in some places that
they can't.
I can go in and sit down and have a meal
in some places that they can't.
I can.
And being greeted on the street and good
Morgan,
you know,
I'm not,
not the brown dude next to me.
He's not.
And His kid definitely can't date the
blue eyed blonde girl at the high school
that's not allowed.
So they basically created these little
colonies.
Yeah.
Yahtzee colonies in South America.
Did you Google Google Colonia dignity
that you will have nightmares?
Do not freak it out right now.
It's done.
It's crazy how many people got away with
it that Joseph Mengele died on a beach
and wife.
I mean,
that,
that would hurt me because he's a guy
like me just on the ops because he,
I mean,
he's a special operations guy.
He was an ss.
Um,
he,
he was,
he was a physical specimen,
especially for the time,
you know,
like we didn't,
we didn't understand.
I mean,
he was,
he was very early on into the,
one of the first real Nazis,
like,
this isn't okay,
all of Germany's going this way.
The chancellor is Adolf Hitler.
This is where we're going.
I kind of just have to go along and you
see some of that in the third,
like 43,
44.
I'm now.
It's okay.
We might be losing this war now.
It's not so invoke.
But when you got guys like 1939 that are
talking eugenics and um,
you know,
higher calling for breeding and
segregation.
Um,
early on you're like,
Eh,
I don't like that guy.
Gonna beat him to death with my hands,
but he's massive.
So it'd be a pretty good fight.
It was a,
there we go form Nazi cult.
Trying to.
What does it say?
Jamie was the full,
uh,
full Nazi Colt.
What is the uh,
so that,
that,
that's just a marketing thing because
it's still the same place.
Reformed Nazi,
cult trying to open it's colony to
tourism.
And where's this?
That's in Chile.
Yeah.
I spent a lot of time.
They're right there.
They made a movie about it.
So that's current day right there.
Jesus Christ.
That later hose in range is freaking
gorgeous though.
It's,
I mean,
it is Shangri a German flag flying.
They've tried to hide the Nazi things
they've had.
I had dinner right there.
Look at them all.
I know,
I know.
That got in the left.
Do you really?
Yep.
What's that bro?
We talked in the butchery there is right
now.
Um,
so I had this guy with me,
Mike Simpson,
he is a,
he works with me a sheepdog response.
He's a doctor.
He was a ranger that became a green
beret that then went to medical school
and then came back to special
operations,
um,
for the rest of the war.
And he's our director of training for
sheepdog response.
He was with me.
He and I both speak Spanish when we were
down there,
but they didn't know that he was a
doctor and they didn't know that we
spoke Spanish and they didn't know that
our translator that looked very Chilean
could also speak German,
perfect German.
She translates for Porsche,
so they thought that they could have all
these little conversations with the
stupid hairy handed.
I'm Irish guy hosts from the tourism
channel that [inaudible] they could get
away.
Well,
we understood everything that they're
saying are they saying.
So one of our tour guides was formally a
nurse in the hospital that they closed
down and we stole one of their little ID
cards to get into that hospital and we
stole a bunch of documents of them
documenting them,
torturing little kids in the hospital
and the hospital.
None of this made the air because it's,
it's.
There's so much litigation going on
where all of these victims of Colonia
dignity that are suing via Bavaria.
And what time period are you talking
about when they were torturing kids?
Like when was this?
Sixties to nineties.
Wow.
And so this is essentially Nazis and the
ancestors of Nazis carrying on those
practices in secret
Jesus Christ.
It's crazy,
man.
Isn't this,
isn't just people that got away with it.
And then their ancestors moved here and
they evolved and changed.
And what you do at that place,
you said the pitchers that,
that,
that place is worth maybe $100,000,000
and they bought that with Nazi money.
What do you do with that?
Where does that go?
I don't know the Nazi money.
We're talking,
we're talking melted fillings from Jews
mouths.
We're talking wedding rings off of Jews
fingers.
They bought that land with that money.
It's gorgeous.
Jesus Christ.
And they have a German colony there.
What?
I Dunno,
I dunno what the right answer is.
I mean,
what,
how does Chili feel about it?
Chile has been in a tough position
because of the amount of power that they
have had their nobody.
So in,
um,
in the sixties,
they were at behest of the president.
They were bringing in,
um,
people that disagreed with the dictator
and they were torturing them and they're
getting that information and giving it
back to the president.
Um,
well that went on for like 10 years.
And so the,
the Nazis were doing that for yes,
for um,
oh my God,
I cannot believe I have whoever the
dictator was so embarrassed.
I can't remember his name right now
because it's around the tip of my tongue
anyway.
But that information they also had.
So not only the information went back to
the president that he could use against
his rivals,
but they also had it so they know all
the dirt about everybody they know who
is having sex with who,
who has a kid with who,
who went to this prostitute place,
who has a deal with the CIA,
who's working with the Venezuelans,
who's working with the Argentinians.
Like they have all that dirt because
they gave it to the president.
They have it too.
So they had been untouchable politically
for 30,
40 years because they had so much power
because they had so much information
because they had so much dirt on every
single high ranking person in South
America.
Jesus Christ.
Now.
That's been a tricky year for me from
that show.
And then straight into hard to kill show
for the discovery channel from going
then deployed to Africa.
Like this year.
I don't even know.
I can't even.
How does that all work while you're
still serving?
Like how do you get the freedom to do
all these different things when you read
after you reenlisted?
So the army will always get with the
army once,
um,
first of all,
but it's got to help them.
Having you be so high profile.
That's a huge presented live of the
military.
If you're listening to right now,
go to your local recruiter.
That's why.
Seriously we are having special forces
specifically we are,
we are going to have the biggest deficit
of eligible up a pool,
a population to select from because you
have to have a certain level of
intelligence,
a certain level of physicality.
Just to be eligible for special forces
to pick from you.
That pool is the smallest that has ever
been in history.
Why kids are playing video games.
They're not eating cheetos.
I'm less participation in sports.
I mean if you could just go to a high
school,
it'll at a high schooler now compared to
20 years ago.
It's a different thing.
Really.
Yeah.
We,
we,
we weren't like barely getting kids past
obesity 20 years ago.
Now in high school
if you walk into a classroom,
half the kids are obese,
so you think this is just because
they're sedentary because they're
playing video games and fucking around
online all day.
It's not just.
It's not me thinking this is us.
Absolutely.
Quantifiably saying we do not have
enough people to to pick from.
Right.
That would be one of the best ways to
really find out what the actual average
health of viable males is.
Right?
Yeah,
for sure.
There's always going to be the best of
the best that want to test themselves.
I mean,
this is just always how it's been.
Yeah,
so we teach 100 forces.
We only have that 100.
We only get six or eight,
but that's a hundred people that go to
special forces selection.
That hundred that goes,
they have to have a GT score.
They have to.
They have to have us scores high enough
on the military entrance exams.
Just to be eligible.
They have to have a pt score high enough
just to be eligible so we can't even get
that 100 and then 100,
only eight or the eight of them are
making it.
So we're.
We're.
This is to answer your question,
how I'm able to do these things is I'm
in a position where I can say for the
love of God,
please get healthy.
Please walk to your recruiter's office
and please take a test to see if you're
eligible because we are just needing
people like we've never needed them
before.
It's scary.
Wow.
Well that's one of the best indications.
I mean most people don't know or people
like me.
I'm 50 year old father,
tax payer out there,
do much.
I'm not paying attention to what fucking
high school kids look.
I don't have no idea.
Yeah,
I do go to like a marine recruiter right
now and be like,
hey bro,
how's your job right now?
And you just fight him from taking that
pen and stabbing it into his own eye
because he just can't get somebody that
isn't smoking weed.
Somebody that can pass a pt test,
somebody that can pass the tape test and
then somebody that can passed was the
tape test.
I'm like,
they're not.
So we measure their neck and their waist
and they can't even pass that.
So the two fat,
the two fat is the neck too little or
too big?
Um,
so if you have a big neck and a big
waste,
this is um,
because like I have a big neck,
right?
But it's from working out.
Yeah.
But I have a tiny little waist so that
gives me my bmi and my body fat.
They measure it.
It's a pretty,
it's a gross measurement,
height,
weight and measurement and the other.
There's only like four things that we
need for some,
for us to say.
And it's harder to get into the military
than it is to get into college.
That's,
that's absolutely true.
Not Regular military,
but special forest.
So regular military wives.
Yeah.
Really?
Yes.
It is not easy.
And then from that we only pick combat
arms and then have that combined arms.
We only pick the top 100.
Is it harder for someone to get into the
military than it is to get into college?
I thought it was fairly easy to get into
the military.
I'm pretty sure anybody can go to
college.
Anybody?
Well,
you can go to community college.
That's college,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I'm not saying that it says easy to get
into Mit,
right?
But anybody can go to any college that
they want,
not any,
any college that can get in and they can
go to
a local community college and then two
years there they can go and get into the
next unit,
you know,
like the state school.
And then from there they can get a good.
I mean anybody can do that.
Well you can't go to the military if you
smoke weed,
you can't go to the military if you have
bad eyes,
you can't go to the military.
If you're diabetic,
you can't go into the military.
If you have asthma,
you can't go.
You can do,
you can go to college if you have all
those things right,
you know you.
You can't go into the military.
If your Iq is x number,
depending on your job,
well you can still go to college.
You can't go in the military if you
can't run a mile or two miles in this
speed and do this number of pushups in
this many sit ups.
I don't think any college has that
requirement,
so I'm just in those seven things alone.
We just,
we just exed out 80 percent of our
population.
And do you have.
Is there also a problem with people's
attitude towards military
with young people?
Yeah,
a little bit,
but that,
that that is mostly a physical issue.
That is way less of an issue.
The perception of the military is way
less of an issue than us just having a
qualified population of viable
candidates for us to pick from.
I mean,
it's really bad where we're.
We're freaking,
we're.
We were borderline freaking out about
what we're going to do.
So an average special force of Oda has
supposed to have 12 guys in it.
Right?
Right.
Now you're not going to find a team that
has more than 10 and
we only have 70 percent of our teams
with 10.
Yeah.
Thank God we didn't go to war with North
Korea.
They got at war ended and that we're not
dropping nuclear bombs.
Anybody because we're in.
We're in a hurt locker for qualified
people.
Have no idea about this.
No,
it's scary.
Wow.
So this is like part of the.
One of the best ways to measure what's
wrong with the way people are living
today.
Yeah.
I mean forget about whether or not they
want to go and serve the,
the,
the viable quality candidates like this.
A number of them that are even available
is the lowest it's ever been.
Well,
what about high school athletics?
I mean,
have they decreased?
Finished?
Yeah.
Really at the same rate.
The part very,
very similar.
The participation in not.
So you can go and play for your,
the rec time volleyball,
but to get onto the varsity football
team or the varsity volleyball team or
the varsity track team,
the number of people in percentage to
the.
So if you have a thousand people,
you had 100 of them that were picked to
participate in those athletics.
Nice way.
Ten percent.
That number now is down to like five or
six percent.
So the,
the overall percentage per capita and
the number of people participating in
these sports has been consistently
decreasing for the past 20 years.
Twenty years in 20 years is essentially
when the Internet became a huge thing.
I mean that's basically the same
timeline you're looking at like 94,
99.
You see obesity going like this,
you've got bad food.
We got to.
Our jobs are getting less and less
physical that the focus on what jobs
people should have.
Everybody's been like no,
go to college and become an academic.
So you can be this intellectual that can
go and do this job.
And then you graduate college with a
student loan and you have no job to go
to.
Um,
where there's this guy that needs
welders,
but it's not cool to be a welder,
so don't,
don't do that or to be a mechanic like
all these trade jobs that are just
begging and pleading for and they are
sometimes physical but they need people.
But it's not core to do that because,
you know,
like I want to go to,
we'll go to long beach state or I want
to go to ucla or I want to go hang out
with a bunch of hot chicks.
Lsu,
you know,
it's,
the focus has been wrong for awhile and
uh,
and that is evident in special forces
selection when we don't have anybody to
pick from,
we can't select,
wow,
why don't we hear about this?
Is this something that I'm trying to
keep hush hush or it has been a problem
because our community motto is the quiet
professionals.
That's our motto.
How do you fit into that?
Yeah,
I don't.
I mean I get so much crap all the time,
but thank God like guys that really
understand what I'm trying to do.
They realize I don't shut up because I'm
trying to help the regiment.
I'm trying the best ways that I can,
the best ways that we can figure out
with people way smarter than me helping
me know I was on the phone yesterday
with some of the best and brightest in
the special operations recruiting
battalion about how were we going to fix
this?
How are we going to market,
how are we going to develop interest?
And um,
so thankfully they're smarter than me,
um,
but we were almost
screwing ourselves over because that is
what,
how we live and that's how we do our
job.
If you read about us on the news,
we failed.
You know,
if you read about army special forces
doing something,
we may,
we have done messed up,
you know,
this is not the navy seals.
We're not writing books,
you know,
we're not talking about our exploits.
We didn't kill bin Ladin.
Um,
this is us just doing our work and
nobody's supposed to know about it.
But because of that,
we now have a huge recruiting problem.
What is the,
what's the approach to try to balance
that out?
Is there any strategies in play?
Yeah,
we talked through a bunch.
Um,
we're trying to figure out,
uh,
you know,
I think
just getting the word out,
letting people know,
one,
we have to get that population healthy.
So let's,
let's go specifically after athletes.
Let's,
let's go to a high school wrestling room
and be like,
hey fellas like this.
That's where I heard about it when I
first heard about army special forces
was a guy in a really bad cut suit from
probably like JC penny's or macy's
walked in,
you know,
and he's like,
hey guys,
you ever thought about army special
forces?
And I was like,
I don't even know what that is.
I like the navy seals.
He's like,
yeah,
check it out.
And he gave us this crappy car and
walked away and I never saw him again.
But that planted that seed,
you know?
And then nine slash 11 happens.
I was like,
I know where I'm going to go into that
dude that had that bad suit.
I'm gonna Find Him Gore for that guy.
So just we're talking about my show hard
to kill.
Um,
you know,
it's not just army special forces,
it's marine recon,
it's the navy seals,
it's air force,
PJ's every special operations that has a
selection process.
They don't have a population to pick
from.
They don't have that body,
that pool of qualified applicants to
select from.
So everybody is having the same problem.
So let's,
let's do the top gun thing.
Let's show how cool it is to be an
aviator.
Another job that we don't have enough
guys,
if we don't have enough pilots.
So was this the motivation behind hard
to kill part of it to get me.
And the reason why I was allowed to do
it,
like we're going to have an episode
every single season where I'm going to
highlight some crazy bad ass military
job doing things that way.
You're going to jump off a Zodiac a mile
from water,
you're going to swim in to walk for
miles with a rucksack to them.
Go do a raid on a bomb makers house
hanging off the side of a players with a
machine gun,
you know,
so just like freaking awesome.
But this is the job.
So let's show them what this job is,
let's show them how hard it is because
it's hard.
This is not easy stuff that these guys
do and hopefully somebody will be
inspired and somebody would be like,
all right,
I'm gonna.
Get off the couch.
So what,
what is hard to kill?
Because I've heard of it,
I've heard the name,
but I really haven't looked into it.
I've tried.
So I tried so hard to get discovery
channel to let you show the first bit of
it.
They won't.
Why not?
I don't see.
They said it's a hurt.
Something.
It's a rough.
It's a rough cut.
And they want everything perfect.
Okay.
Well when they get it perfect,
send it to me.
We'll play it.
So we find a job that is inherently
dangerous that people die and doing and
is necessary for our way of life.
That's the first part.
We find whatever that is that um,
that might be a guy that changes light
bulbs at the top of Cell Towers.
That might be somebody that's hanging
off the side of a building,
Washington windows.
That might be an experimental test
pilot.
That might be somebody that works on a
bull ranch,
um,
it might be a guy that delivering
antibiotics in Alaska to families that
live out in the bush.
So it's not necessarily military jobs
now we'll,
it's jobs in general.
No,
no,
no.
I think we only do one military job in
this first season.
I thought,
oh,
okay.
Because I have a very distorted
perception of it.
I thought hard to kill was all about
military.
Nope,
just one.
It's,
it's anybody anywhere that does
something necessary for our way of life
and they die doing their job.
That's,
that's the show.
And I'm trying to highlight and I'm
trying to pay homage and respect to
these people that nobody thinks about or
appreciates,
you know,
like let's walk on our southwest flight
and we're like,
Hey,
uh,
can I get my beverage service and my
peanuts man.
But in the fifties and sixties,
the average life expectancy of an
experimental test pilot was like four
years.
You know,
you have stories that these sr 71 pilots
that are flying at mach two and the
whole entire thing just disintegrates
around them.
One of the guys has killed instantly,
the other guy starts falling.
I think there's like 30,000 feet in the
air strapped to his chair.
So we can't even use this parachute.
He wakes up,
he's blacked out.
He can't look at it as visor because his
visors frozen and he just did a deadspin
fallen at 200 miles an hour at any
lives.
How?
Because he's amazing.
So let's,
let's,
how did he live?
Well,
I recreate that whole entire thing in
the show.
Did that.
I'm full stupid.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm done man.
You did that?
Yeah,
I'll come over there.
It's very tense.
How did this guy survive?
So he wakes up,
um,
he,
he's in a free fall.
He strapped to his chair.
His parachute won't deploy his visors
frozen.
Um,
he gets his harness off and then he goes
into the box which is free fall
position,
which kind of stabilizes.
Super impressive that he knew how to do
that in the first place.
A lot of pilots never even practiced
free fall.
So He's free falling.
And first,
let's remember,
this guy was a combat pilot in Vietnam
and in Korea.
So,
um,
this,
this guy has been,
he's actually been shot down before,
so pretty heroic fella and he gets out
of his harness,
he's in the box,
he deploys his parachute in the box
again.
How do you do it?
You're,
you're,
you're pretty much driving your hips
down as a massive sprawl.
Okay?
That's what it is.
It looks like you're driving your hips
down to massive sprawl.
Your arms are pushed back,
so air is evenly flowing off of your
body from spinning.
It makes you stable.
So the air,
the friction of the air off of your body
makes you stop spinning in circles or
tumbling overhead.
And he,
because of his,
um,
center sat parachute,
he naturally had weight on his hips,
which dropped his hips down.
And then he just kind of stabilized,
coincidentally through his parachute and
the lat landed on his records,
which was on fire.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Which we recreated for me too.
I got burnt pretty jacked up.
They put me inside of a experimental
test plane,
put aviation fluid on it,
locked the cabinets,
are locked the cockpit,
and then set it on fire with me inside
of it.
Why do you do this?
Because that's not even like real,
like you're choosing to do this.
Yeah.
But they did it.
They did it and they survived.
And you're doing it to recreate it in
their honor.
What we have,
I mean,
there are there,
there are safety measures in place where
like I only got,
Kinda got burned so my shirt got melted
in my.
I was able to get out of my seat belt
because my seatbelt melted.
Um,
but I thought out because it melted.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
And then I was able to,
I couldn't get the cockpit open because
the cockpit held.
Mel had melted,
so I just tore the cockpit open.
Um,
but we are maybe one or two seconds away
from the fire department just descending
upon me to,
to save my life and then take me to the
hospital.
So the motivation is everybody I think
takes for granted all of the things that
we have in our life and there are some
pretty heroic,
courageous people that risk at every
single day to do these jobs,
to get our food,
to get our oil.
Like that stuff is pumped from the
center of the ocean.
Sometimes know there's a guy diving
down,
breathing helium and nitrogen at a few
hundred feet,
messing with gases that if he cuts just
one millimeter to deep,
he's going to get sucked into the pipe
because the negative pressure,
you know guys that are flying a plane,
there's no test dummy for flying a
plane,
right?
Some dude is going to sit inside of a
plane sometime and be like,
let's say fuck it.
Let's see if this works.
Yeah.
Think about the whole thing on that too.
A lot.
So that's the whole point was we wanted
to show and there's hundreds and
hundreds of people that do these jobs
that we just don't think about in the
middle of a hurricane.
Like how has your power still on.
There's somebody out there trying to fix
it.
You're,
you're in the middle of a blizzard and
just feet and feet of snow or descending
on.
There's power lines and you think
they're just staying up there?
No,
man.
There's somebody hanging off the side of
that tower that's negative 20 outside
and he's trying to fix that stuff.
So you.
So your heater stays on so you don't
freeze.
Are you going to get one of those planes
that flies into hurricanes?
Yeah,
man,
we do the dumbest stuff.
Are you going to do that?
Yeah.
You are?
How about putting me at the bottom of a,
of a mountain and setting off an
avalanche?
What?
Yeah,
let's do that.
Take it.
Are you going to do that or are we.
Did that?
Oh Dude,
don't die.
Don't die.
Am I like you?
An [inaudible] to helicopter and the
Arctic Ocean and go and crash it into
the ocean and then make me swim to an
iceberg and live on the iceberg.
Did you do that?
Yeah,
I did that because somebody else did on
the iceberg for I was too,
too cold account.
Um,
what I had to do once I got to the
iceberg,
I had to get my,
I had like these tasks that I had to do
for them to come and get me.
So once the helicopter went underwater
and I had to swim down into the
helicopter and the water was 33 degrees
and then I just swam,
I think it was about,
um,
a few hundred meters and it's 33 degree
water is about 30 minutes total time in
this 33 degree water.
I fortunately was able to bounce some
ideas off of Calkins,
Berrien and uh,
went hoff and a bunch of guys from on it
because they,
they're pretty into that cold weather
stuff.
Cold.
What did that mean?
What does kyle know about swimming in
the ocean?
He doesn't three degrees.
He knows about the extreme temperature.
Um,
he,
he does the contrast showers and like
the heart rate breathing.
And so I was just trying.
I experimented a bunch of it before I
went and did the episode to make sure I
didn't die.
How much time can you spend in that
water?
I thought it was only like a few
minutes.
That's what they said.
Um,
and uh,
I wonder were in there for 30 years.
I want to see how long I could do it.
Um,
so once I lost small motor function so I
couldn't move my hands,
um,
I could still swim.
So then once I could have my arms went
next but I could still kind of do the
eggbeater kick from swimming and water
polo and that lasted about another eight
or nine minutes and then it was Kinda
like I was just trying to keep my head
above water.
Um,
and then they sent him the rescue diver
and pulled me out.
Fuck Dude.
Took me four hours to get moving to,
to be able to move again for hours.
They can't,
they can't warm you back up either.
So they,
like they put you in a sleeping bag but
no heater and no,
you have to very slowly because you can
go into shock if you warm up too fast.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
It's,
man.
I should have,
should've been a golfer.
It wouldn't have worked.
Tiger Woods is surging again,
you know,
like,
yeah,
what the heck.
But yeah,
you would have got bored.
So there's um,
a Bush pilot and Alaskan Bush pilot
that,
you know,
they like deliver food to these people
living out in the middle of nowhere in
Alaska and he's flying to
an engine stops.
He's like,
oh,
that sucks.
So it auto rotation is,
they still have a little bit of lift
from just the friction of the blades so
they kind of can control because the
blades are still kind of like rutgers.
So you're talking about a helicopter
helicopter so they can somewhat control
their descent.
So he finds an iceberg and he's like,
oh,
I'll go crash by that iceberg.
So it goes and crashes by the ass near
the iceberg and the helicopter
submerging.
And he dives into this emerging
helicopter to get his survival
equipment.
And then he swims over to the iceberg
and he sets his kinda like shelter up
and then he has to fight off polar bears
for a couple of days.
He lifts this,
this dude survives.
And he,
he was like,
the source for our Bush pilot episode
was this one guy,
but there's hundreds and hundreds of
stories of these guys crashing all the
time.
So we just try to figure out what the
job is,
why it's hard,
why it's dangerous.
And then what is the worst case
scenario,
what is the worst day on the job?
And let's see what that's like.
How do you find off the polar bears?
Um,
so he,
he,
he had a raft like the,
his flotation raft,
and it was an inverted,
which he had turned into like a small
Igloo and he could hear the bears
starting to come up to.
And it doesn't get dark there.
It depends on the time of the year.
Suddenly had like one or two hours of
darkness.
Um,
so we could still kind of see and he
could see the bears coming.
So he was sitting inside that just
hoarding super still and they could just
smell that something was off.
They're trying to figure out what it was
and then it would stand up with his raft
on his shoulders and back were banging
on the big plastic you rafting and this,
you know,
they could figure out what it was
because it was just 12 by 12 raft rising
and running with them and with lots of
noise and that's.
And he was able to scare them away I
think three times before you finally
rescued.
Oh my God.
No weapons,
no weapons.
Oh,
fucking Christ.
Yep.
Ooh,
I don't have those balls.
Well,
you would if you were there.
You do whatever you had to do if you
were there.
Polar bears scare me.
They scare the shit out of me because
they actively hunt us.
Oh yeah.
The one of the few animals.
I mean,
that's all they do is eat meat.
Anything that moves largest car on a
more on the planet.
Yeah.
Do you ever see that video where they
took a guy from BBC and they put them in
a big giant glass box,
like a plexiglass box and put them out
into the Arctic and polar bear came up,
was trying to bite through the box and
figure out how to get him.
So he's inside the box filming it and
this thing could smell them and it's
just opening its mouth is as big as this
fucking.
That's when you really get a perspective
of how large they are and it's trying to
bite into this box.
Here it is.
Here's the guy.
So the thing comes up to him.
I mean we're.
Hey,
this is the Klondike bar thing.
This is the Guy Likes Coca Cola.
No.
So giant Super Predator and it's trying
to figure out how to get smart too.
Yeah,
well they have to be.
So he's got this.
I would've checked that lock like
$50,000.
I don't understand this box trying from
all angles.
Look how big that is.
That box would have smelled like shit
for me if I were in there right now.
That's all you could smell in that box.
Yeah,
man.
It's such a strange task.
I mean,
I don't know.
There's a boat behind him,
I guess.
So the dude with me with a tranquilizer.
Hopefully.
Rifle.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
It's trying to figure out how to get
them.
It's a,
it's a very disturbing video.
And it went on for a little while.
The thing left and came back and left
and came back again and finally they got
him out of there.
Fuck that.
It's amazing.
It's crazy animal.
Yeah.
We couldn't find a polar bears.
Did you want to?
I did.
I'm always going to try to scare them
off that way.
Yeah.
I'm kinda ended really badly.
But another poor decision in Tim's life,
uh,
the,
the discovery channel,
this is the most expensive insured show
they've ever done,
I would imagine.
And um,
they're just some things
we,
we know shit took explosives,
tnt through them from the side of the
helicopter to cause avalanches
that I'm,
that I'm in.
And so do you have one of those
inflatable suits?
It keeps you from getting completely
compressed?
Yeah,
we tried that one time
that I definitely use that and I think
that saved me one time.
It kept me up on top.
So those things don't keep you from
being compressed.
It keeps you on top.
It's like a flotation device,
a life preserver for the snow,
so it gives you more surface area of
friction which rises you to be like when
you have a big jar of pebbles and you
shake them,
the biggest ones go to the top.
That's all that's happening is you're
trying to make yourself the biggest
pebble to raise you to the top of this
huge friction.
So because most people,
they actually die of traumatic injuries
during the avalanche,
not from a fixation.
Really.
Uh,
even though when they finally put me in
the avalanche,
I was low.
I was inside of the snow for 30 minutes.
That was the amount of time that the
network would let us,
would let me see if I could survive.
And I had a,
I had a,
a button,
if I clicked it every minute on the
bottom of the minute,
they would leave me in there for another
minute.
So I stayed in for 29,
59 and so as soon as it's over 30 they
were like,
that's it.
That's all the time we allow.
Yep.
Wow.
What was it like in there for really
cold?
Yeah,
it was super cold.
It was dark.
It was hard to figure out which way was
up.
Um,
so I figured out which way was up
because I was able to,
like I took my snowboard and goggles and
I put them over my mouth.
So the snow went side initially have a
little bit of um,
a few breaths of air because what
happens is you get a ice seal around
your face from you exhaling,
melting,
it freezes.
So then you have this cocoon of no fresh
air coming in.
So,
um,
I was able to.
So I locked my hand inside of my helmet
and I held my goggles over my mouth so I
would have a little bit of air.
So then I was able to take that off and
get it over my son and I have a little
bit of air here and that was like moving
snow with my pinned hand too.
But then I saw a drip of water drip off
of my glasses at a 45 degree angle to my
left.
I was like,
oh,
up is that way.
That was.
That was like the best thing for my
brain to know which way up was because
that was the only way you could tell was
because you just your waiting list and
snow.
Wow.
That's a crazy feeling.
Like you don't know where the up is.
Yeah.
So up could be your feet.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And you wouldn't even know.
So I just gravity watching that drop of
water drip off of my snow goggles as a
Qa piece for my brain.
What if it went up?
I would've,
I would've pissed myself.
What have you spit and you go up,
you're like,
oh no,
I got to go with that date.
And there's no moving.
Either get rescued or you freeze to
death.
And so there's.
This is not a controlled avalanche.
They're just actually starting an
avalanche.
Yep.
How many of these episodes are you
planning on doing,
Tim?
I mean,
can we stop now?
Nah,
I think we've got a bunch of people that
the world needs to know about that,
uh,
that we take for granted how we get our
food,
how we get our gas,
how we get our.
And uh,
I think I got a bunch of special forces
recruiting slots I need to fill and this
is the way to do it.
I hope cells killing yourself every
week.
I didn't.
I mean I went,
oh,
I almost only died three times in this,
in this first season.
Um,
and if somebody is like,
that's a cool job or weight,
the only way that Tim,
I'm there,
there are some times where you're
watching me inside of a cockpit that's
on fire.
And the only way I got out is because
I'm a savage.
Like I'm just a beast.
I was like,
I'm not,
I don't feel like getting burned alive
today.
So I tear the cockpit open.
I think somebody at some point it's
going to draw the conclusion that I was
able to do that because of physicality
that if you're a fat person sitting
inside of there,
you would be burnt alive.
And maybe they'd get off their couch and
they go and do something.
Maybe they,
uh,
there's a weird way to motivate people
want anyways.
A good way.
I'll take it.
I don't know whose idea was this for
this show?
That was my idea.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you're an unusual human.
It's fun though.
And how many of these episodes have you
done?
We have finished six.
And you're going to that.
Is that the entire season?
Yeah,
that'll be seasoned.
One comes out in July.
You excited about it?
Yeah,
I'm pumped.
So 50 percent of the time you almost
died.
Yeah,
I mean that's gross math.
Rounding around.
Okay.
So there's the water one.
Well you almost froze to death.
Yep.
That definitely.
And then the avalanche one way you
lasted 30 minutes.
What was the other one?
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Worse.
I mean it was,
it was,
it was less pleasant.
I'm like,
I was a bull fighter for an episode.
Oh Dude.
And not a bull rider because they're
insane.
But the bull fighter is the guy that's
on the ground.
So when the bull fighter gets thrown,
he's the bodyguard for the bull rider.
His only job is to take the hit.
So the bowl writer doesn't get trampled
to death because the moment the bull
rider comes off the Bulls back,
the bowl is turning around to crush
whatever was on his back and that's
where the bullfighter runs into save
him.
And uh,
you know,
the PBR,
the professional bull riders
association,
um,
those guys are the most selfless,
courageous guys trying to protect those
bullfighters,
um,
bull riders.
So I trained for a while and I was,
went to the biggest rodeo in the nation
and was bullfighter and um,
I mean this isn't one of those shows
where people don't get hurt,
like you see the inside of my body.
You see people get really,
really,
really jacked up and go to the hospital
and like it does.
You have a punctured lung.
Is that guy going to live?
This is that type of show because
there's no other way to do it.
The only thing,
the only direction we had from discovery
was don't fake anything.
That's a great direction.
That's great direction.
The glad they came up with that.
Now what happened with the bull?
Um,
I got owned,
which is humiliating because they're not
really smart animals.
You're fast over there.
Jamie's a wizard.
Yeah.
To encourage all little boys and girls
that follow me on any social media
platform to stay in school,
become engineers,
architects,
accountants,
or anything that doesn't lead to
permanent brain damage or need of an
orthopedic surgeon.
It's you legs up at a bowl watching you
through the air.
That was the training week.
So this was when you were trying to
distract the bull.
What kind of techniques do you use a
football running back stuff.
Just Joo Kim.
Um,
the,
the thing is you actually have to sell
that body movement.
So like your weight,
your weight has to shift far enough
where the bowl is going to really
believe that you're going to go to that
direction.
Um,
I wish bowls were so I wish they're
dumber than they are because they're
not.
Because if you fake them once one
direction,
they won't take it the next time
they'll,
they'll you try to fake to the right.
They'll already start going right into
left,
so then you flick to the right,
you go back to the left and you're like,
oh no,
I have done an.
It's at that moment that tim realized he
had fucked up,
you know,
then it just gets own.
I got destroyed.
And so when you get launched into the
air by a bull,
it's,
it's weird,
um,
because it's,
it's weightless,
you know,
it's just a second and you are
completely inverted.
No control over where your body is going
because you didn't generate the energy.
Um,
but the other part of you,
the other part of your brain is knowing
that that bowl is going to try to turn
as fast as it can and get you when you
land on the ground because that's what
it's really good is when you're down.
Yeah.
So you're trying to keep track of where
this bowl is while you're hurling
through the air.
Like,
okay,
I've got to Tuck my chin so I don't
break my neck,
you know,
hopefully I'm not close enough to the
fence.
[inaudible] the fence doesn't move.
The fences,
metal,
you know,
the ground is pretty soft.
I'd rather land on the ground then
landed on the fence.
The fence will mess you up.
Anyways.
So that's that up.
And how'd you get away from the bull?
I'm an athlete.
I'm not sure if you know that.
That's it.
Just athleticism.
Yeah.
Luck.
Little luck.
No luck that you didn't get stomped now.
So there was some,
some,
some real bull fighters in the ring with
me that I think saved my life every
single time because I suck.
I at the end of this show,
people are gonna.
Look at this
and be like,
one.
Tim is an idiot to everybody that does
this job.
These jobs has the biggest balls and our
show.
Bad Ass.
Hopefully that's what they're gonna get
because this isn't like a Tim Kennedy
look.
Cool.
Show.
This is,
that guy's an idiot.
And everybody else is pretty fucking
picture.
Oh my God.
Look at that picture.
Notice that.
That's a different bowl.
Did this more than once.
So this,
this bowl is.
He's got his feet up in the air and his
head is inches from you and it's about
to collide with you and there's no
fucking way you got away in this
situation.
There's no way that things way too
close.
What is it like to just get a launched?
Two thousand pounds a fucking meat
vehicle?
It's the other things that I'm
so the.
We did a commercial fishery for a
commercial for fishermen is an episode,
a deadliest catch,
stuff like that,
but you know the,
the.
Those shows in this episodic way.
They really go into the personalities
and the people that do these jobs,
I think they really go.
They gloss over how hard that job is.
I'm the there on this decks for 14,
15 hours working a net poll to a net
poll to put out a net to next,
and then they go in and the net is out
and they have 45 minutes to sleep before
they have to pull the net back in and
they do that for 28 days.
So they're getting like cat naps.
So then slowly their,
their,
their cognitive ability is starting to
diminish and their physical capability
is starting to diminish and so
everything is.
But then they're on a platform that is
intended to 12 foot waves that slippery
and the water is 38 degrees.
So everything about what they're doing
is setting them up to die.
So that again,
those are great shows.
I love it.
Deadliest catch.
And um,
I think there's a handful of their shows
now,
but I don't think it has ever gotten
close enough to showing.
I mean I've always been.
I did that job for one day and I was
like,
I just need a break dude.
I don't think there's any way you could
really accurately portrayed unless you
did a 12 hour show and showed you.
And then multiple 12 hour show.
I mean if they did a live stream of you,
that would be the way to do it,
right?
Like there's satellite feed somehow have
an internet connection showing you
fishing for 12.
So you can just tune in.
Here's Tim still fishing.
I want to go to sleep.
I'll wake up eight hours later,
get coffee,
get breakfast.
So we check out Tim,
look at Tim,
still awake,
one wrong step,
one wrong,
not,
and you've got to count on these other
guys that are also exhaustive.
One second,
if you have one second to realize where
that person went.
If he's in the water one second and he's
under,
you know,
fuck in 38 degree water with 12 and 12
foot swells.
And you've been out for 20 days.
And what kind of fish were you catching
there?
I'm there.
I think we're pulling scallops.
Those were scabs.
So the stuff that was just pushing off,
like we weren't even using any of those,
we're just pushing them back into the
ocean with a lot of scabs.
They're like these,
um,
the like little sting rays.
Oh,
they'll chop them up for sometimes.
That's all.
That's all the stuff.
So the bucket to my left,
that's all the um,
the fish that we had picked.
And this is the leftovers.
Whoa.
That's an inefficient process.
That's crazy.
So all those things die so that you can
bucket.
Oh,
they're still alive.
Yeah.
Those go back in the water.
Oh,
okay.
And so what's in the bucket there?
A scallops
clams.
Um,
wow.
How crazy is that?
All that stuff gets scooped up and you
don't want it [inaudible].
That's bizarre.
Yeah.
Actually,
I think a second after this photo was
taken,
I took a step and I stepped on one of
those things,
see it?
They kind of match when they're facing
down.
We'll know in their belly up when
they're white,
but when they're brown and facing down
it's the same color as the rust.
The deck.
And I stepped on one that I thought was
the deck and in my,
in my right hand right now,
that is a,
it's a pike.
It's a spike with a,
with a nail sticking out the end of it
that you,
that's what you use to sort.
And I step on this thing and I fly.
I mean my,
my,
I swear my feet were all the way up at
the top of that wall.
I five,
five feet up in the air,
just inverted flying through the air
with 12 foot swells in the sea and a
spike holding onto that spike and I'm
two feet,
three feet from the edge of the boat to
Jesus Christ.
These guys do it all day long.
You know,
I hope you liked the.
That fish that you walk to the
supermarket and pluck out at whole
foods.
You know it got there somehow.
If it says wild caught,
it's freaking wild.
Caught is we have a real problem with a
disconnect from things like that.
Disconnect from food,
disconnect from how difficult these jobs
are.
Where's the fucking power?
The power going back on.
Somebody is out there,
so he's out there in that blizzard it.
I mean you could look at.
I think that's one of the things that's
wrong with the society right now is
everybody is just taken for granted
everything about their lives.
They just want it easy.
They want it fast,
they want it quick.
That's what people are getting fat.
That's why they're going to the grocery
store and getting the thing that's on
sale.
That's why they're getting mad at guys
like you that go and talk about hunting
because they just want the easy
solution.
In truth,
be it.
There isn't an easy solution that's the
right solution.
Usually it's the hard way.
Usually you know the other.
There can be a smart way,
in a smart way,
sometimes is the hard way,
but everybody wants this quick fix.
Everybody wants to take a pill and they
feel better.
Better.
That's not how it works.
You know,
like you can't pain or suffering from
depression and uh,
like you,
if you've been having these thoughts,
I'm going to take a pill and feel
better.
While that might be a portion of the
solution,
how about you lose 10 percent body fat?
How about you get off the couch?
How about you go make out with your
wife?
How about you go down on her for a
couple of our gear,
a bunch of Orgasms,
then have sex with her and then go to
the gym.
Promise you're gonna.
Feel better after that.
You know,
instead,
I'm just going to do.
I'm going to have this easy solution and
it just doesn't work.
So I,
I mean,
I think for me the show is hopefully an
opportunity to give people.
It's not that easy.
We've made a weird society.
We made a society where we've nerfed all
the hard edges and we're trying to make
it safer and safer every day and there's
some things that just,
they're just messy.
They're not going to be safe,
but us making everything safer.
It's making us weaker now,
you know,
in,
in every time that we've had a weak
society,
we end up with tough times.
The tough times make hardman that
hardmin make good times than good times
make weak men than weak men know.
And the cycle just keeps going.
And right now we have week.
We can't even,
we even allowed to say men,
just the men out there.
There are some,
but like,
I don't even know if we're allowed.
Like I just driving,
driving here to your studio.
I saw the girl scouts office is one
block away and your neighbors that have
no security cameras right back behind
fries with their backdoor lodged open
with.
I'm like all of that right here in la,
but more importantly to girl scouts,
which isn't even a thing anymore.
Now it's just the scouts.
There's no boy scouts and there's no
girl scouts.
There's just the scouts and in a week a
half a million members of the boy scouts
have left because you can't have just
boy scouts.
You have to have just scouts.
Is that what's going on now?
Is that how they're doing it?
Yeah.
And a half a million scouts have last.
I mean that if you go on these camping
trips,
the boys and the girls go together.
Yep.
That sounds like a good idea.
If you know,
that's bad.
That's bad idea.
Kids get raped.
Yup.
For sure.
It also changes things.
I don't know how I feel about,
um,
I think women in the military to be able
to go anywhere and to include special
operations if they meet the standard.
But
when you have a girl present,
it changes.
Men Act differently,
yes,
period,
and it changes the chemistry of the team
and when,
when you're trying to raise men,
when you're trying to rear boys and have
them becoming men and you're doing
these,
you know you're taking them horseback
riding or you're teaching them knots or
you're showing them how to set up a tent
or how to purify water.
If there's a girl there,
the focus isn't on time.
That Boland the focuses on is Christina
watching time,
my Bolin and while that's good and bad,
it's bad.
If you're trying to have an opportunity
to,
to nurture elements that are very
beautifully separate equally for girls
like I can we teach Christina that
Bolin?
Absolutely.
Can we teach how to ride a horse 100
percent,
take her hunting.
She'd be willing to do everything that
every one of these boys should be doing.
I believe so,
yes.
Boy,
in that mix,
it changes things.
It changes things.
Yeah.
That's why I've always been supportive
of all girl gyms.
I'm like,
they should be able to have a fucking
gym when no one's trying to bang them
100 percent.
I mean,
there's a lot of women that want to be
able to go to the gym and not have
somebody ogling them and stare at their
ass when they're doing squats.
But all boys gems.
You watched the title fight get
squirrely this last weekend.
Which one?
Um,
let me Chanko or Amanda.
Amanda Nunez.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
I did
think if those were two.
So at the end of the,
in between the fourth and fifth round
when I'm Raquel Pennington,
warner pendants and said I went out and
her team said no,
that it would have been different if it
was two male fighters.
I think it would have been.
I think it would have been as well.
Yeah.
One,
I,
I believe that had her team let her out.
She would have regretted it the rest of
her life.
Um,
the failure and it didn't happen by her
team there in between the fourth and the
fifth round.
It happened in preparation,
getting her ready for that because I
think
that,
those words would never be uttered out
of my mouth in the middle of the fight.
Um,
it would be my team begging and pleading
for them to end the fight.
Um,
I don't know if there was a route for
her to win that fight.
There was a path to victory for her.
I don't think that there was.
Um,
and I think she felt that,
but
I think the journalists,
the MMA media attacked her coaches
unfairly.
One because she's a girl.
I think that played a part in it.
Everybody's like,
oh my gosh,
this girl fighter in between four and
five.
She's just a fighter first of all,
right?
And her coaches know her better than
anybody.
I'm not defending what they did or
attacking them.
What I'm saying is you're not on either
side of that fence and you've never had
your feet on that canvas and felt the
fury and pain of defeat and the
sweetness of success and the worst thing
ever is regret.
And I have you.
You feel like she would been,
even though I absolutely agree,
that there was no path to victory.
Yep.
I think Amanda Nunez was,
she was searching,
she was destroying her.
Her nose was shattered.
She's getting beaten down and she didn't
have anything left turn and so she's
like,
I want out now.
Big John Mccarthy and I talked about
this yesterday and he feels that his,
that the coroner did a big disservice to
her by letting her take a in that fifth
round that every fight,
take something out of you and some
fights take more out of you and there
comes a point in time where there's a
tipping point fight and that that could
have been the tipping point round,
that she might not ever be the same
again.
And he was saying that,
you know,
you've got to understand that you only
have a certain amount of holes you can
punch in your ticket and if she,
especially when you're talking about
someone who's that ticket off the
tickets of fight card,
right?
That's the ticket.
Yes.
It's not,
she's not a,
she's not a janitor.
Her,
she only has to fight again or be beaten
down so badly in that fight that she's
never the same physically.
I mean we have every time.
So we talked about this with Robbie
lawler.
Michael is being,
but it might be the case with Robbie
lawler.
I mean if you look at Robbie lowers last
fight with Javiel dos Anjos.
He didn't really look like the Lara
volt.
Now,
could that be because of dos Anjos very
well.
Could have been.
Dos Anjos is a beast in our business to
tell him when he's dealing.
It's not.
It's not our business.
Tell him he's done it.
His ticket,
but it's his ticket.
What if he wants to quit?
Could I says if he says he wants out.
Like she said she wanted out.
Like there's certain times in a fight
where someone says they want it.
Like here's a good example.
Do you remember Jeremy Mclellan when
fought Nigel Benn?
Yeah.
This was the fight that put him into
this catatonic state and bleeding on the
brain.
People are criticizing him because he
took a knee.
People were saying like the commentators
are saying,
what is he doing?
Why is he doing this?
Well,
he fucking knew something was wrong and
he took a knee and then blacked out and
then eventually had bleeding on the
brain.
Like you,
Gerald Mcclellan was a beast,
I mean world champion boxer,
but he knew something was wrong.
Now,
if Raquel Pennington had said,
uh,
I won out and our coach said,
no,
go back in there,
and then she goes back in there and
collapses and as bleeding in the brain
and winds up in the same state as Gerald
Mcclellan,
then people would be going crazy.
Um,
I know your point because that's the
kind of fighter you are.
That's the kind of fighter you were.
You were a die on your sword guy.
That's,
that's what you always did.
And you had some fucking amazing fights
because of that attitude and that never
quit mentality where you were in there
to win or die trying.
God,
I'm so scared of that regret though.
I understand it.
I don't know if all the things that I
have to because I have
mentally checking out at the end of the
year.
Well,
Ramiro fight,
you know,
I regret that to the day I die that I
didn't stay because I'm looking at Dana
anticipating my money.
You know,
Marty,
look at and be like,
Hey,
you know,
you're going to pay me for this one.
This is one hell of a fight,
right?
Looking,
thinking about me destroyed Michael
bisbing and that's what he's already
thinking about.
I had already left the ring.
So I have that regret,
that like nags at me.
Um,
I can't even imagine what the regret
would be like for me not to go out all
the,
all like all my,
I don't have posttraumatic stress,
but all the things that nag at me,
it's the things that I didn't do and it
sort of,
but aren't those things would make you
better.
The realization of the mistakes that you
made.
Those are the lessons and that's what
makes you a stronger person,
but you don't do,
you don't get stronger by doing the
right thing every single time.
Part of getting stronger is by fucking
up and having this horrible feeling that
you fucked up and realizing you never
want to feel that again.
Yep.
Yes.
That's how muscle and that's how our
brain works is you damage it and it
comes back stronger,
you know?
And I think that's how the human
condition is to a degree,
but you know,
like the hurry to failure of the rush to
failure or um,
yeah,
that's how you get better.
But I want that,
that point where I'm going to fail to be
so unattainable and so hard to reach
where if I ever reached that point of
failure and I,
I mean I,
every time I go to the gym and I'm
training on it and I want you to come
and hang out with us one day if you ever
make it back to Austin.
And we try and find the quitter and each
other every single time that we train
every time.
And that's what we say.
Look,
we even have workouts called find the
quitter.
And we have,
we have guys,
professional athletes from all sorts of
sports come in and join us and they,
they will quit in the middle of,
in the middle of one of our just
strength and conditioning workouts.
And it's because my little group,
Shane one myself,
we are looking for that failure and it's
getting so hard to find just like
shooting.
I'm looking for that miss [inaudible]
that misses that opportunity that I'm
going to get better.
I'm looking at that,
that,
that rep that I just can't get or that
5:30 mile one more time,
you know,
because that's going to be the
opportunity for growth.
So I agree with you,
but it also has to be hard to reach
because failure should never be
easy.
So you think her being able to say I
want out that she still had enough left
to keep going.
I don't know.
I think only her in her corner are going
to know that.
I would say.
I would say that I agree with you except
I have so much respect for her and I
think she's one of the toughest girls in
an mma,
one of the toughest people and she's a
fucking animal.
Raquel Pennington.
She really is tough.
I'm a big fan of hers.
When someone like her says I'm out,
I'm done.
I just think she's beaten down so badly
that she doesn't physically have the
ability to fight anymore.
And then she went out and proved that in
the fifth round and took a ferocious
beating.
But she agrees with you,
she agrees with her coaches,
she agrees.
She says now after the fact that her
coaches were right and that she had hit
this moment of weakness.
If I sit on the stool in my coach and I
told my coaches,
I went out and you know I got Great
Jackson Winkle,
John,
Nick Palmisano all sitting there and
they let me out.
I would hate them forever.
I would.
I would regret my decision and I will be
mad at them forever and they're there.
They're,
they're some of my best friends.
Now.
What if right after you said that you
collapsed and they took you to the
hospital and they had to open up your
skull to alleviate pressure on your
brain because you were bleeding and your
legs stopped working and you're in a
wheelchair,
electrical McClellan trying to relive
the past through distant foggy memories.
That would be less than ideal.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
I understand what you're saying.
It's like the balance of the physical
limitations of the human body and then
the limitations of the mind and the
minds willingness to find a way out,
which brings me to the one thing that I
wanted to get to before we leave.
This is waterboarding and this is,
this is something that came up because
you were defending.
What did gail,
Gina.
Gina,
what is your name and spell?
Spell.
And she is the person that was being
appointed by to lead the CIA.
Yup.
And there was a bunch of people that
were saying that she shouldn't be
because she advocated torture and you to
defend her,
decided to get waterboarded.
Yup.
We've actually been talking about this
for the past hour and a half.
Yeah.
We have,
we've been talking about it's
the slow erosion of,
of the human condition.
US getting softer and US getting weaker
and US getting nerfing the edges and
finding the easy outs and the easy
solution.
Um,
the conversation of middle ground,
finding a way that we can communicate
with people and have a discussion.
Um,
so we've been,
we've been having this discussion for
the past 90 minutes and um,
what I have is a bunch of people that
are sane what something is,
but they don't know what that is.
Man.
I know what torture is.
I've seen it in Africa,
I've seen it.
South America,
I've seen it in the Middle East.
I've seen it on almost.
I'm pushing 20 trips overseas in a
military capacity,
a handful of combat deployments,
you know,
from looking for poachers,
human traffic,
ears,
drug cartel.
I'm kind of piracy.
The things that I have done,
like you want to talk about knowing
intimately what torture is.
I fucking know what torture is.
Pouring water on of face is not torture
Kate,
if you starve them,
if you beat them,
if you isolate them,
if they're there for,
you know,
you're the only getting the yes,
we can start adding things onto it.
But the,
the thing that was the most irritating
was everybody's just throwing out this,
well,
let's talk about morality.
And this woman is immoral to be in this
position.
I remember people jumping to their
deaths on nine slash 11 because they
didn't look at burnt alive,
right?
And then I saw a guy on his knees and
have his throat slit open by somebody's
pulling his hair back and sliding that
knife across his throat.
That was one of the guys that she
interrogated,
not I'm not saying two wrongs make a
right,
but she interrogated them to get a
question,
to get questions out of them,
to try to save more Americans.
The intent was to try to save more
lives.
They say,
okay,
well if it's not that bad,
then why did it work and this is why,
and this is what nobody understands and
because they can't understand the
difference between the easy way and the
hard way is because these people that we
were waterboarding are cowards.
They were pussies.
They're impotent little bullies their
whole entire lives.
If I put you on that water board,
I could waterboard you for days.
You have your moral convictions and you
would never change because you believe
in what's right and wrong and that's a
great and beautiful thing.
They're not you.
They're pieces of shit that that throw
acid on,
little girls that fly planes into
buildings because it's capitalist.
That's who these people are and if
they're only tough when they're
surrounded by 60,
70 other of their friends,
but you take one of them away from that
and you put them in a in a position
where they're powerless and that's what
waterboarding is to powerless and they
cave and they cower in seconds.
Like I don't need to drive a nail
through their hands.
I don't need to pull their teeth out.
I don't want to take a drill bit and
drive it through their fingernails.
That's torture.
This is us pouring water on a cowards
face and they freak out and people can't
understand that because they can't
understand what these people are and
their animals.
The,
the,
these,
these aren't beautiful religious people
that are trying to do the best thing for
the families.
These people were the worst of our kind.
These were the Nazis of the 19 forties,
but this is the current version of it
and the these radical fanatics that are
doing anything for any reason to hurt
anybody so they can feel better about
themselves and you take them out of that
power.
They take them out of that control.
You take them out of that opportunity
where they can be the bully and they're
just shadows of themselves and then they
give you everything that you need and
what you need is an opportunity to save
more lives.
Well,
there's two.
There's two things that were discussed
about this one,
that your situation that you were in was
not in any way similar to the situation
they were in because you were doing it
with your friends.
You knew you were going to be okay.
You willingly did this.
The whole process was very controlled.
You.
You weren't being held by people,
spoke a different language in a country
that hates you.
It's,
it's a situation where you knew you were
safe,
so you could relax yourself and calm
down and tolerate it to the point where
you knew that you would be okay.
Yep,
and what was the other side?
The other side is if torture works,
isn't that the best form of torture
you're going to be?
Okay.
I mean,
if,
if torture does work,
and I don't know if torture works.
I've never been torched.
I've never been around torture.
And I know there's a debate both in both
torture doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
Doesn't work.
So that's not torture.
No.
So you think you feel like that works,
but torture doesn't.
So I think maybe we're
arguing about vernacular and verbs or
you're forcing someone to do something
they don't want to do and you're,
you're freaking them out.
Yeah.
You're doing something physical to them.
So
I think we just have to define torture
if,
if it's me doing something to somebody
that makes them uncomfortable is
torture.
I mean me asking a pointed question that
somebody in an interrogation room down
at lapd could be torture,
right?
You know,
um,
if you smack him in the face,
is it become torture?
Yeah.
Is that,
is that torture?
Right?
Um,
well if I know if I hit him with a phone
book,
maybe the problem is the word,
maybe the problem is defining the word
your,
I mean,
then they called it enhanced
interrogation techniques when,
if you're trying to get information out
of someone that would save American
lives,
it seems to me,
I may be ignorant,
but waterboarding seems to me to be one
of the most humane ways to do it.
I,
I agree with that.
You're not going to do any permanent
damage to the person.
It's not like what they did a John
Mccain when he was a prisoner of
Vietnam.
That disturbed the shit out of me when
that guy was on Fox News and he called
them songbird mccain because he was,
he was saying that,
you know,
terrorism.
That torture other worked on became
like,
how could you stoop like that?
I mean,
how,
how could you do that?
I mean,
you,
you know,
what that guy has been through to
humiliate him and humiliate yourself by,
by,
by taking that position on television
like,
that was so disappointing.
It's
about usable information.
We're,
we're,
we're questioning and if you cross that
threshold of torture where you are doing
damage,
physical damage,
where they'll tell you anything that's
not usable information that you're going
to say that you've been dating your
producer for seven years and secretly
like I could get you to say anything
under the right conditions that doesn't
do any.
Just want to stop the pain.
Yeah,
just anything to make it stop.
Um,
that's not what was happening here.
And,
and when we start talking about
morality,
if they're saying,
okay,
if this is a moral act than,
than okay,
this make me and all of my friends that
have done all sorts of,
some in some cases,
terrible things are we now a moral
people because we did it in the interest
of protecting our country and serving
our country and,
and providing protection for our
freedoms.
And Hey,
I know those are cliche phrases that
people grab onto and I don't want to,
but it then by extension,
throwing and lobbying those accusations
at her extend to a to me and to,
to the things that I've done.
And I think I'm a very moral person.
And I try to be a good person in every
way I can imagine.
I'm not perfect,
I'm not,
but I try and the politics of bleeding
over and misusing words,
manipulating everything just so it fits
your agenda,
but nobody's in the middle of the
ground.
Nobody's a green and nobody has the best
interest at heart and that's the people
like the best interest should always be
serving the people and none of them are
doing that.
They only care about what is going to
get them reelected or what's going to
give them more power,
was getting more money from the lobby or
what's going to give them more
clout for the next vote.
What's going to give a little handout
from the president or what's,
you know,
whatever games that play that happened
on the beltway.
That's what the.
And that was an example of that in the
most horrible of ways because it came
down to a human lives.
It came down to somebody that had been
serving their country since the eighties
in the best way that she knew how,
in the ways that we're legal for her to
do it,
and everybody else just manipulating the
narrative to fit their agenda when I'm
just sitting here being like,
how about the people and how about
freedom?
Who's fighting for us is,
where are you guys just going to keep
bickering about this?
So me strapped,
starving myself to that board.
Um,
I'll tell you,
it's harder.
Do what's easy is to lay there strapped
and have somebody put water on your face
too.
It's hard.
When I did to Steven crowder,
watch his hands where he'd reach up and
pull the.
He couldn't have,
he couldn't take it.
He would pull the rag off his face.
So many times I pulled the rag off my
face,
not once,
right?
Every single time I said,
no,
no.
Poor longer.
No,
no.
Use the host.
Use the bucket right now.
You're at a two.
I need you at an eight.
Now I need CIA interrogation friends,
right?
And I'm sitting there willingly with my
hands.
What the sensation of me drowning as
that water's running into my sinuses,
showing that was intentional.
I understand.
People are like,
oh no.
He was safe.
He wasn't even tied down.
I did that to demonstrate how a man of
resolve can do it effortlessly and how
it's not torture because I could
willingly lay there with my hands free
to pull the rag off at any juncture,
but I did it.
I just sat there and I asked for more.
I understand that,
but I also understand the position that
people take where they say,
you knew you were safe and so this is
why you had this resolve.
You are.
You're not in enemy soil.
Being interrogated by isis being
strapped down by them where you didn't
know what was next.
If you think this,
what would be next,
let's say Rachel maddow from MSNBC,
because we agree on so much,
she's like,
Hey,
I want you to come onto my show.
I'm going to bring in five CIA
interrogators and we're going to do it
live.
You're in control of nothing.
Do you think the result would be any
different from not the same?
Because you're on a television show and
you're still,
you're,
you're Americans are going to do this to
you.
You haven't been captured.
You're not an enemy soil.
You're not.
So how far did on how far do we have to
go?
You have to kind of be the person who's
really captured is really capture.
It's not a game.
It's like if you get choked out in the
street,
you can't tap out,
right?
If you get into a physical fight to the
death of someone and they take your
back,
you can't tap out right in this
situation,
you know,
you can tap out,
you know that even if it's cei
interrogating you and they're yelling at
you,
there's a part of your brain that knows
I'm on Rachel maddow show.
They don't kill soldiers on Rachel
maddow show.
This is true.
Um,
so I don't know how I could better have
illustrated.
I think you did a fantastic job.
I think the problem
lies in it's impossible to really
recreate it without you being an actual
prisoner of war.
Um,
do what we do,
uh,
reverse the roles we're talking about
snatching these guys from their bomb
making facility in whisking them to
upgrade and pouring water on their face.
What happens to me and my friends when
we're captured,
we waterboarded no,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not saying that what they do to us
makes what we do to them.
Right.
But I'm saying is it's better.
I'm saying it,
it's better.
I mean,
so that's what I was saying before.
If it is torture,
if you want to use the word torture,
like we'd use the words drugs,
right?
Drugs are coffee and it's also heroin,
They're all drugs.
Caffeine is a drug,
right?
Torture.
If you're just going to say torture,
I'll take that torture every day because
he knows what that is.
Yeah.
Because even if it sucks,
yeah,
I'm going to start to live.
I'm going to be slowly,
carefully,
methodically,
painfully murdered.
Yeah.
And that's my only option there.
There is never any other option.
If I got captured,
there's no moral equivalency.
I think we can both agree there's no.
I mean,
between us and them there's not.
But here's the thing,
mccain himself said that she shouldn't
be appointed because she willingly
participated in torture.
He said that.
Yeah.
The,
what did you think about that?
I've one respect his opinion.
I,
the things that he has done,
whether we agree on things
are,
is irrelevant.
His,
his resume speaks for itself.
Agree and I think very few people could
speak to torture better than him.
I agree with that as well.
Um,
so him coming from that position and
saying that she isn't eligible to serve,
um,
is very powerful statement.
Um,
I also feel that I'm pretty intimately
familiar with torture and that I
understand the full spectrum of,
of what somebody can do selflessly for
their country.
And I'm selfless selfishly for their own
satisfaction as a psychopath.
I'm like Zarqawi's enforcer that would
go around and kill people in front of
their own family members had carried
around a battery power drill.
And I saw that we tracked him.
So
I also know that when she was doing all
of these things for her whole entire
career,
one day were you have to look at the
context of the time and what was
happening.
Um,
and when she did every single one of
those things,
they were authorized techniques.
They were encouraged,
they were successful in some degrees,
um,
to some degree and so she was trying to
do the best that she could in the,
with the,
in some cases limitation that she had.
Um,
and I think that is a trait that I want
in somebody leading the CIA that is,
that they are going to do the best that
they can with what they have and what
they're allowed to do.
And
I liked that,
I realized that,
but this isn't someone who's talking
about this in the,
you know,
the comfort of a boardroom.
This is someone who's dealing with it in
time of war and you're dealing with some
of the most horrible people that we've
ever experienced it or making these
videos of cutting journalists heads off
and sending them to their families.
Yeah,
I mean this is,
this is,
this is really what
we were experiencing when people were
deciding to use these enhanced
interrogation techniques.
This is what they were up against.
This isn't something you can discuss in
a classroom and and get a full sense of
the tone and what was happening in these
people's lives.
Nine slash 11 was the tip of the
iceberg.
When that happened there,
there were hundreds of other plans to do
similar things with that.
One was just successful.
They had been trying to others and they
have tried other sense,
whether it's a shoe bomb,
whether it's a parish train,
whether it's a San Bernardino bombing,
whether it's a,
a,
a garbage truck and France,
you know,
or London Bridge.
It's any,
any.
They have consistently been trying to do
that and duplicate and replicate that.
The reason that it hasn't happened again
to that scale to that level is because
of the uncompromising selflessness of
heroes trying to protect Americans.
Now I don't want to go into what is the
greater good care?
Are we losing morality coming?
That's a rabbit hole that we could talk
about forever,
but man,
I just want to preserve life.
Why do you think that concept is so hard
for people to grasp?
Because Gary,
well,
not just that,
but the concept that the reason why this
hasn't happened more often is because of
these people doing the heart work.
Why is that so hard for people to
understand your skin hard work?
I just made a guide to MTV show just so
they could see for the first time that
people work hard so they can have food
and they have work hard.
They get of oil and they got power that
people.
They may look at a post when I don't
have a shirt on.
Everybody says men tend to loving being
off Usada.
I've looked the same sense as 19 years
old.
I have looked exactly like this with the
same eight pack,
with the same muscle definition since I
was an 18 year old kid.
I don't even know how many times I've
been tested from the military for Usada
to different events.
I've been cleaned my whole entire
career,
but nobody can in their mind.
They can't understand to get from here
to there is hard work.
No,
there has to be an easier way.
It has to be steroids or it has to be
this or it has to be that.
It's the same way.
They're protected and they're safe,
but they can't grasp the idea of the
hard work that it took to keep them
there.
I don't even
think they're thinking that deeply into
it.
I think they're just talking shit.
I think people see you.
You Look Jack Storage.
I don't there's that much thought,
but
I think it's.
I think it's the same lack of thought.
It's the same lack of consideration of
what it took for us,
for us currently to be safe and what it
still takes for us to be safe.
That's,
that's the departure.
that's the break in,
in,
in the thought process is they just want
the easiest way and they don't want to
even believe that this hard way is the
way that actually has happened.
What is the alternative?
What's the alternative suggestion and
instead of enhanced interrogation
techniques,
waterboarding,
instead of letting the CIA do what it's
done up until now,
what is the alternative I can.
Does anybody offered in,
you know,
in response to that instead of doing it
that way,
do it this way.
I mean now we're just leaving them and
nothing.
We're leaving them all be great for how
long
years?
No,
it's.
It's like now they're in perpetual
purgatory for eternity
that there is no other solution.
Nobody's presented one.
They're just complaining about the
options that.
Exactly.
But that's the point is that there's no
one's said,
look,
the CIA has done a terrible job.
This is the way to do it.
Right?
They're just saying,
I don't know what that is.
Torture people.
And I agree with that.
Yeah.
Shoot.
People with paintball pellets.
Don't shoot him with bullets.
She,
you know,
hit them with rubber bats.
Don't hit them with.
What are they saying?
If they do you think part of the problem
is the vast majority of the population
will never truly understand combat.
They'll never truly understand what
people are capable of in the worst case
scenario.
God,
I hope so.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hope that 99 percent of this
population never has to see any of the
things that we've seen otherwise,
uh,
failed.
Do you think that maybe it wouldn't be
the worst idea in the world to force
people to have some sort of mandatory
service,
whether it's mandatory service in the
coast guard or whether it's the peace
corps or whether it's the military,
just some service of your country for a
predetermined period of time like they
do in Israel like they do in South Korea
like they do in several other countries.
Yeah,
I would love that.
Do you think that that would fix things?
I think he's give people an
understanding of what's required.
Like send people to Afghanistan for six
months,
let people understand like,
holy shit,
like God damn,
Kansas is pretty fucking bad ass.
How about to send them to El Paso?
A more come down there on the Flores?
Yeah.
I mean I understand that the world is
not San Francisco.
There are dark places and you could see
that on cnn all you want and look at it
on our t until you can smell it until
you live it.
Until we,
I have to take these pills every single
day,
which gives me the shits or otherwise I
get malaria.
We are,
they are all these people walking
around?
Are they taking these pills?
Oh,
they're not.
They,
some of them have mullet.
Oh,
we're the having that reality
sink into them.
That way I'm going to eat that goat and
I have to pull the pieces of hair out of
my mouth that that's the reality for the
majority of the world.
It's um,
I would love for somebody to force
everybody to have a taste of hard work.
Well,
everybody wants something free,
right?
They want the government to do many
things for them,
provide services and do things for her.
But the government is essentially just a
group of us and a group of private
versions of us.
I don't want anybody telling me I have
to go do something.
to go serve somewhere,
but I don't think it's the worst option
to get people if we really hit a pivotal
point where people have such a complete
lack of appreciation and understanding
of what it takes to make the world work
correctly.
That might be one of the only viable
solutions is some sort of mandatory
service for some agreed upon period of
time.
It doesn't happen when you're young.
I don't think.
I think a war fighter should always and
only be volunteer.
I agree with you.
Um,
but man,
serving your country for two years,
working on the border of working at a
homeless shelter,
um,
humanitarian aid,
working in a hospital.
I mean all the different things that we
could do with all of these people that
would have their eyes opened.
Um,
I think it strengthened people.
Could,
I think it could their,
I mean,
their character,
their soul,
their bodies,
their minds,
all of it.
Yeah.
Just being forced to understand that
there's a lot of messy work that's
required to make this thing work
correctly and we all benefit from it.
But a lot of us benefit from it and just
sit at home and play video games and eat
cheetos and do nothing.
And you still complained about Mexicans.
Sneak out.
It's fucking crazy.
You know,
everything that we want,
whether it's success or food.
Good looks.
I'm at a beautiful girlfriend,
girl,
beautiful boyfriend.
All of that is always just on the far
side of hard work.
Everything.
I don't know.
There's some dudes I've never going to
get a hot chick is you work all day.
Shit rolls of the dice out.
They're genetically.
There's just,
it's never going to pan out.
Everything I've ever wanted has always
been everything I've ever had.
Everything I've ever gained,
every,
every bit of who I am has always been on
the far side of hard work.
Um,
the Lance Armstrong and I were talking
and arguing about a performance
enhancing drugs,
you know,
when I fought for two world titles and I
lost two world titles,
you know,
he wants seven and um,
but he was in the dirtiest of dirty
sports.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he said,
doesn't Tim Kennedy,
you know,
world champion.
Doesn't that sound better?
You know,
and yeah,
it does,
but I would have lost everything because
everything I've ever had has been from
hard work and that would have been,
is he trying to justify his own
existence dummy.
What's happening there?
And also it's a different sport.
You know,
it's just a different thing between no
one gets hurt.
If you take epo and you run your bike
faster,
it doesn't.
No one gets hurt if you're on something
and it allows you to beat someone's
brains in better and you walk away from
a title knowing that you cheated,
but the guy you beat was natural.
That to a guy like you is a torture.
The you're going to be,
you're gonna be in prison and the rest
of your life with that thought bouncing
around in year head,
that's not the same thing.
So the same thing when we guys like
Vitor Belfort who failed multiple tests
were world champions multiple times,
sort of he really only one once against
randy because randy got cut memory.
You got that crazy icon and he won the
tournament when he was 19,
but even then he was sauced up so he
still feels like a world champion to
him.
I would never want that.
I'm not.
I'm not rationalizing,
and he paid the price though is and he
will pay the price,
but I mean he paid the price physically.
You look at the transformation between
TRT v toward that,
knocked out luke rockhold.
We'll kick and Michael Bisping,
Dan Henderson.
He was a fucking monster and then the
deflated version of him where his body
is,
endocrine system's failed.
It doesn't produce testosterone anymore.
Can't take a punch anymore is he doesn't
look even remotely similar to what it
used to look like,
don't.
It's?
I'm look at the difference between him
and then look at Yoel Romero.
Okay.
Yoel Romero is 40,
41 years old.
He looks the same older than Victorville
and he's fucking jacked.
Obviously you're dealing with
significant genetic advantage and you
all said that when he was on the
podcast,
you know,
it was a great podcast.
I don't know if you saw,
but Joey Diaz translated for them back
and forth,
you know,
they spoke Spanish and then translated
to English,
but he said if you go to Cuba,
it's like regular people,
regular people you see a bus,
drivers jacked.
He's like,
you're dealing with a phenomenal gene
pool here.
They're baseball players that come out
and you're like,
they touched the ball and it goes over
the fence.
I mean,
there three printers.
Let's say this is the,
this is the dark,
dark aspects of the slave trade.
I mean,
this is what you're dealing with the
best of the best,
the strongest,
most athletic,
the ones who can work the hardest.
Those are the ones they wanted.
That is essentially a big part of the
gene pool that is Cuba.
Then you deal with the decades and
decades of extremely high level athletic
performance,
uh,
with the,
with all these different sports and all
these different programs where they
develop the very best athletes in the,
in their area.
I mean they just,
the wrestlers,
the boxers,
the judo players,
I mean phenomenal athletes and that the
gene pool is just outstanding.
The,
um,
Hector Lombard,
another physical example,
but looking at vidors body shrink and
you will stay the same mindset,
the same.
Um,
what do you think the heart,
not the actual beating cardiovascular
system,
but like the soul of Vidor,
he visibly looked deflated and every one
of his fights post Usada he knows he's
going into that in a compromised state.
So when he was going into it,
like when he got tested,
one of the times,
one of the reasons why the whole
testosterone replacement therapy got
eliminated as,
or got tested randomly and he was off
the charts like,
look to the point like superhuman levels
of testosterone.
They're like,
what in the fuck are you doing,
man?
Like you,
you have this massive advantage and
massive confidence advantage and just
physically looks like a demon,
right?
One that when that's gone,
now you're less than a regular man
physically and mentally,
physically and mentally because you're
tired all the time.
Your body's tired.
You're not producing good levels of
testosterone.
He talked about it openly about they
tested his testosterone.
So the testosterone was 70 year old man
and he's fighting in a cage for living
at a very high level.
I don't know the um,
I still think it comes down to hard
work.
I think it certainly does,
but all the hard work in the world.
If you're built like,
you know,
fucking Kevin Smith.
No disrespect Kevin.
I love Ya
marrow.
Yeah,
just fucking Yoel Romero is going to
pound your face into the dirt every
time.
Kevin Smith is a millionaire that is
massively successful in what he wants to
do and disaster.
Super smart that it didn't go into cage
fighting and he works hard and does a,
you go all the way back to the beginning
when he's writing scripts and he's doing
standup comedy.
That dude was the first.
They're the last to leave and then is
success is not,
is unquestioned.
Yeah.
No,
I agree with you 100 percent.
He most certainly worked hard,
but I'm talking about genetics.
Like there's genetic.
I mean Francis and Ghana has freakish
genetics.
I mean,
you know,
obviously a steep meo chick also has
very good genetics.
Still a giant person,
but the genetics and Francis have has in
comparison to the average person.
You could work all you want.
You're not competing with that.
Yeah.
There's some people that just get a
shit.
Roll the dice.
He uh,
he also lost his title fight though.
Buddy lost a steep way who was also got
pretty fucking phenomenal genetics.
He's a giant duties,
tough as shit,
very skilled and has a just a lifetime
championship.
No experience.
Like,
I don't want to say anything nice about
that guy.
First of all I get that.
It's hard for me to say anything nice
about him,
but he,
he,
that guy worked hard,
worked hard and toughest shit.
Became the world champion and he looks
he has,
he's had a bod
for forever.
I don't ever remember looking at him and
be like,
that's a scary dude.
I look at him,
Oh my God,
I want to fight him.
And then like take that British accent,
shove it down his throat and then make
fun of him.
They make more videos about them than
beat them up again.
Well,
he's been clean his whole career and
never,
never looked back like a guy who was
doing anything suspicious in his hard
work.
Hard work that made him a warm champion.
Got toughness.
All right.
No more talking.
Nice about that guy talking about
anything else,
but what,
after you retired,
can you just let it go with a guy like
him or did you guys talk so much?
Shit,
I was just talking shit still.
Yeah,
no,
totally.
I mean I've never really had a real
problem with anybody,
you know,
in 17 years as a professional fighter.
I mean I could pick a couple of
instances like we,
he,
Mike and I would never be friends.
Like we're not going to go drink a pipe
together,
but like,
why not though?
I think we're just different people,
but why not now?
If he retires and you retire.
Oh,
I mean we're just different during the
airport.
One day we'd totally hanging onto each
other.
You're at a bar,
like,
let me buy you a drink.
You Fuck?
Like what?
What are we talking about?
Hunting?
Or we're going to talk about a shooting.
Let's wish they were,
we'd drink a pint,
like we're never going to be friends,
but I would totally sit down,
have dinner with them and talk about the
good old days.
And um,
because you won,
it also helps me.
I don't even think about it that way.
No,
I was like Luke rockhold know I'd sit
and talk to him [inaudible] I'd sit and
talk to him.
You know,
we gotta get you out of here because I
know you got it
flight to catch,
but I want to tell you at all my times
of calling fights,
one of the most powerful experiences
that I ever saw really wasn't even
televised.
It was in between you,
you knocking out Sapo in the fight for
the troops and you got on top of the
cage and all the troops were there
cheering you on and nobody there was.
Nobody wasn't televised.
There'll be saw this,
but you were pointing it all those
people and saying,
I love you.
I do this for you.
And they were cheering and it was a
fucking powerful moment.
Man.
That was a powerful moment that to this
day I think about sometimes because that
was a different kind of a fight.
It was a different kind of an audience
and it was a,
it was a different kind of a moment.
And when you launched that left hook on
him and connected him and stopped him
and then jumped up on the cage and did
that.
That was that audience.
The love they had for you.
And the love you had for them was it was
in the air,
man.
It was fucking amazingly powerful.
I'll
never forget that moment to the day I
die.
Not,
not the fight,
not the fight camp.
Um,
I couldn't breathe.
I had so much love for everybody.
That was like,
I,
I would have melted out of fan ost
myself,
vaporized and taken every one of my bits
and just handed it to everybody there.
Um,
and not existed just so that they could
have anything that they wanted because
there was just nothing
in me that I wanted more than just to
give them anything I had.
Um,
and I think I believed that it came out
when you,
when you were saying what you were
saying,
the way just,
you could feel the,
the,
the honesty and sincerity in it.
I'm not a good liar.
I got to work on that.
No,
don't work on it,
Tim Kennedy or bad motherfucker.
I appreciate you.
Keep doing it,
bro.
I will.
You too.
All right,
that's it.
Bye everybody.